and we don't want to inconvenience them
by starting our meeting late so I would
ask you all to now mute your computers
and stand and join representative
Bernardi who will lead us in the Pledge
of
Allegiance flag the United States of
America
stand
representative again good morning
everyone I am representative Michael
Vose and as chair of the house science
technology and energy committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order 20
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
of a bill referred to the science
technology and energy
committee executive session on pending
legislation may be held at any time
however there is no plan to do that
today please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting
also by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house House calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
HCS ledge. state. NH .
Us in the event that the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and
rescheduled staff assisting us this
morning is Jennifer for who is our
committee researcher later today will be
assisted by um another staff
member please note that all votes that
are taken during this meeting shall be
by roll call
vote we'll start the meeting by taking a
roll call attend attend when each member
states their presence please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to no law so Mr
clerk please call the role I shall do so
ch um representative Thomas I know is
out of state so he's absent
representative
Harrington
Harington
representative n here representative
mner
here representative here representative
B here representative Bernardi here here
in
committee representative C presting
committee representative
present representative white I'm here
and I'm
alone representative
Sage uh I'm here at my home and my wife
p represent c
p representative I see her she's there
you can see me representative ple who's
taking the roll call I am representative
PL and I I'm too busy looking at my
screen representative man cut your
picture off don't look at your
representa president I'm at home uh and
alone at the moment I'm unable to get
engaged uh represent
Vincent I'm here at my home and my wife
alone I'm here in the car with my kids
represent
preaching I'm here home alone represent
pel here home alone so there are three
pres um pardon me I may have missed my
name oh Lu Marshall yeah I sorry about
that I did and because it's on a second
page and I also didn't ask for the chair
not a problem thank than you uh so
representative par you are here oh and I
alone my room okay and I will ask the
chair obviously pres I'm present in the
committee room all right so that doesn't
change my count there are 18 present
and thank you Mr clerk we appreciate
that before we open the public hearing
on Senate Bill
113 I want to just briefly go over the
plan for the day this public hearing on
Senate Bill
113 will take uh the first hour of the
day then at 11 o'clock we intend to
convene a work session on Senate Bill
78 at 12 o'clock we will take a lunch
break we will return at 1 o'clock at
which time we will begin a work session
on Senate Bill
91 that work session will probably go at
least an hour possibly two
so we should be concluding our business
for the day around 3
o' so with that uh scheduled explanation
I will now open the public hearing on
Senate Bill
113 and ask the prime sponsor of the
bill Senator Jeb Bradley to come to the
uh floor and introduce the bill welcome
Senator Bradley nice to have you back at
St stn it's uh the floor is yours uh
good morning Mr chairman I'm trying to
figure out what the mountain background
is behind
you I think it's the weeks no it's Mount
pod as actually okay well you got me
very good so good morning um again for
the record Jeb Bradley um from wolfboro
pleased to be uh the sponsor of Senate
Bill 113 and I want to thank the uh the
bipartisan co-sponsors of that bill I've
already indicated to Chairman Vose that
I think the best course of action for
this bill is to be retained in committee
to give The Advocates uh more time to
try to build the consensus necessary uh
for it to move forward so let me just
very briefly say what the intent of the
bill is it is designed to ensure
consistency within our uh RPS s in New
Hampshire so that we enhance uh
smallscale renewable electric generators
in New Hampshire with a
consistency of alternative compliance
payments across the board at
$55 I think um passage of this bill
would have a very limited um impact on
New Hampshire's electricity rates rates
excuse me given the low price of
renewable energy credits today and I
think if you look at um some of the
documentation from the Public Utilities
Commission about the RPS um RPS costs
are very very small in the overall
scheme of electric bills um it makes at
$55 across the board alternative
compliance payments uh technology
neutral which I think is a good way uh
to encourage competition amongst the
best options for technology uh one thing
that it does do I think I should point
out if you look at um line five of the
senate pass version of the bill it adds
hydrogen derived from water currently
right now um hydrogen does qualify for a
wreck credit if it's um comes from um
biomass fuels or methane uh there's a
new technology that a company in the
northern part of New Hampshire is
pioneering uh that would make hydrogen
from water and so it applies the same
technology neutral standard for that
technology so happy to answer any
questions I think there are probably a
number of people uh that will testify in
favor the bill the Senate to pass this
bill I believe on a unanimous Vote or
almost unanimous vote um and we commend
it to you but as I said uh Mr chairman I
think given the ongoing need to build a
consensus best option for this bill is
it okay thank you Senator Bradley for
that introduction I do have one quick
question for you if we do retain this
bill would there be any usefulness in
extracting the portion of the bill that
talks about hydrogen from water
extracting that portion and adding it to
another
bill uh you know what I I think that
that would make a lot of sense Mr
chairman whether you choose to do it in
the house or or potentially we choose to
do it um in the Senate I think that is
is a standalone issue and I um encourage
that thank
you okay why don't you and I uh talk
about that offline and we'll figure out
the best way to go with that
okay chairman the chair now recognizes
hi thank you Mr chairman
um uh and thank you Miss Senator Bradley
for coming to testify um Could you um
explain to our committee a little bit
more the role of the um the um
alternative
compliance uh payments and how that
affects small scale generators right
now a different price yeah thank you
very much for that question um an
alternative compliance payment is
something that a distribution utility
would enter into if there are not um
renewable energy credits available and
it's a way of um
encouraging uh the production of
smallscale renewable energy resources in
New
Hampshire so followup Mr chairman follow
up so my understanding is that the ACP
payment is sort of the floor for price
of of of these uh generators is that
correct that's
correct thank
you chair recognizes representative Cali
question good morning Senator uh I
looking at uh some of the reports and I
I think the last one I looked at was 218
we going into 219 and 220 some of the
classes that were going to go up to $55
are now running now at 26 and and lower
So when you say
minimal impact or not so much of an
impact
on rates and on the
producers if something is going to go up
or Jump by
40% almost
50% is that going
to uh put an undue burden on some of
these
producers well I wouldn't put an undue
burden on the producers and and I the
Distributors I would um also
remind the
committee that um this is similar to
legislation that covered years 20171 18
and 19 which expired so that's why um
the price impact would be nominal and I
I would further say and I don't have it
in front of me but I believe every
October the Public Utilities Commission
publishes a report of the impact of the
renewable energy portfolio on rates in
New Hampshire in a in a pi shaped graph
and I think if you look at that graph um
the cost of renewable energy credits is
pretty small in the
overall um cost of constructing
rates may I follow up you
may uh when I'm looking at
at at the the
payments
um I think at this point there's in
legislation is 35 or
$36 and now we're going to go to 55
across the board some of them are down
to 26 is there a reason that we took
that level and put it across the
board without letting a due study be
done and I know the bill wants to be
retained so are you offering or are you
saying that we need to retain it until
we see the new studies well well I think
that you raise a point as to why the
committee might want to retain the bill
um again the across the board nature of
it is designed to make it technology
neutral fuel neutral um and encourage
you know the most competition possible
and to align you know the classes at
that
$55 um amount if you look in the bill in
the struck out portion
um at the bottom of the first page of
the bill those are the um years in which
it was either $45 or um $55 so that when
I say it it's returning to you know the
status quo prior to uh you can see it
right in the
bill as it struck out I I had one more
question uh yes go ahead the other
question was that when I was looking at
the and I did read and I did read the
rsas and uh refresh my mind but when
when this bill comes up it looks to me
like it's going to be
retroactive and is it proper to pass re
legislation
retroactively I would think a year or
two out would be better but it looks
like the way it's written it may go back
is that correct well that's my
understanding if you look on the second
page of the bill the 2020 class rates
are those in effect as of December 1
2020 right so the bill would in effect
retroactively is that that's my
understanding please correct me uh you
know my brain isn't functioning so
well uh
um how
that comports with
lines for instance 28 through 30 on the
prior page um where the prior rates were
in effect um you would probably be best
to ask the anybody testifying from the
Pu but it it should um the intent is to
maintain those rates that were in effect
um prior to the expiration of those
rates thank you if I made myself clear
thank
you okay thank you the chair now
recognizes representative PL for a
question and representative PL does not
have a mic does not have a mic so hang
on thank you um I understand the intent
to make it uniform why make it why not
make it uniform at a lower price like 30
instead of 55 and make make the burden
on rate payers easier so
representative the point of it at $55 is
to provide a floor for um smallscale
indigenous New Hampshire resources there
are quite a few jobs that you know are
dependent on this um it obviously is a
diversification of our energy uh
resources and again um I think if you go
back to the
documentation provided to your committee
to the Senate um that pi-shaped graph
and I wish I had it in front of me I
apologize I don't um it's a fairly
small
um cost of the overall cost of a bill
and if we do nothing you at $30 you'd
basically be
maintaining um what's already in effect
for class three and class 4 go up
down okay thank you Senator Bradley uh
representative McGee is recognized for a
question yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you senator for coming here to
testify today I know you've already
answered a few questions about why
consistency um among the classes is I
think it's a great idea so people can
actually have it in their mind and
understand what the rates are instead of
them all being different but I was
wondering if you knew if other states
also priced their um RPS
classes the same um in order for I guess
the distribution companies to do true up
in an easier way uh I I don't know if it
simplifies the process and I guess
that's what I'm asking is um would it
simplify the process if we have a
uniform rate well I suspect it would
simplify the process but you kind of
have me on not knowing the answer to
what other states are doing and I
apologize for that well that's okay I
was just I was just curious if it was a
common practice or not to um to to keep
the rate agnostic so that they would all
be
equal well again I think the rationale
for for it being technology neutral with
a uniform rate is to encourage
competition and and um the
best um use of those dollars um to
produce you know the energy at that rate
I think technology neutral encourages
competition and followup Mr chairman
follow up and um and along those lines
the the 45 and 55 that were in the
paragraph that's scratched out at the
bottom of page two um those rates were
not just arbitrarily set right they were
they figured out that that was um an
appropriate floor when they first set
them so so yes I mean that's correct
representative uh you know the point of
trying to adjust these rates is to make
sure that as I keep saying the small
scale indigenous New Hampshire renewable
energy producers have that um floor and
and
obviously um you know with the price
pressures that these small scale New
Hampshire resources are
experiencing um that's what had been
judged in the past to be necessary the
$55 is a small bump up but it goes back
to what it was in
178 and 19 I guess the last thing I
would say um this bill I believe in an
identical form just updated for the
dates um was passed by the house and the
Senate last year was in one of the
Omnibus bills that did not survive the
process okay thank you yep
representative Bernardi is recognized
for a question thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you Senator uh I'm going to
continue to uh inquire about this this
floor and why it's 55 there had to be
some logic there had to be some work
done to to develop the the basis for
that floor I I would like to understand
that can you shed light on that for me
please so I've been saying it's a floor
it it it really is both a floor and a
ceiling at the same time um the price
point because of the competitive nature
of a renewable energy credit is very
unlikely to ever go above the $55 but it
does also function as a floor and it is
hoped that it will ensure that these
renewable energy producers you know can
stay
viable up so was there some kind of
analysis done on on that some kind of
financial analysis that says this is the
floor point that we need to focus on so
over the last several years um with a
passage I believe of Senate Bill
129 that I
sponsored uh last year's bill I believe
was House Bill 1580 and again now at
Senate Bill 113 I think the testimony
over that um three-year period of time
that both you folks in the house and
those of us in the Senate have heard is
that that price point we hope is what
keeps those renewable energy providers
in New Hampshire viable without it
having you know a harmful impact on
rates thank you thank you thank you uh
representative bintel is now recognized
for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you Senator
Bradley um there from what I understand
the the right the rates for
Rex are way below this 55 or even the
$21 price tag here in New Hampshire is
anyone actually spending money on acps
time um you'd have to ask that question
of the puc folks but you're right um the
wrecks are available right now at a
lower price um and this um at $55 again
I keep I feel like I just keep repeating
myself but it's designed to try to make
you know those um producers viable and
it goes back to you know what cill 129
established in I believe it was
19 followup Mr chairman ahead follow up
and my other question concerns your
your um your desire to have this
retained uh to build consensus and I'm
just
wondering what aspects of this build you
need to to get consensus on um it seems
pretty
well it's a pretty simple bill so I'm
not sure that there's consensus at the
$55 um ACP amount and um Mr the sponsor
of the bill I'm going to hopefully be
able to work with all of you folks and
build that consensus so it gets through
the
process uh a followup Mr chairman one
more question follow up go ahead thank
you Mr chairman Senator Bradley right
now we we made this number 55 35
105 um it's kind
of not doesn't make any difference
because they're not even being used so
why not just move forward with this
$55 price tag which appears to be
reasonable to
me um
again it I
think there's been some controversy
about this bill I have heard from a lot
of different folks on both sides of the
debate both the price point but also the
need to keep you know these producers
viable so I by asking you folks to
retain it I think that um offers a
consensus thank you Mr chairman thank
you uh Senator Bradley yep thank you
thank
you Senator Bradley I have one question
for you since the bill sets all the acps
to a single price is there any rationale
whatsoever for a combining
classes in the
RPS if we're going to have a single
price for acps why not just combine all
the
classes there might be some rationale
behind that that that's been an idea
that's been explored for some time as
you know representative o um I think
there just amongst the providers in
class one two three and four um there's
been some angst about that and
opposition to it you know that would be
a useful question to ask some of the
people that will
testify behind me but that's been the
reason why I don't think it's ever been
done in the
past okay thank you Senator um actually
there is no one else uh signed up to
testify that's why I asked you that
question but I appreciate the your
answer and also just before you get out
of the building uh just wanted to let
you know that picture of Mount podes was
taken from Mount Hedgehog well there you
go so thank you uh Senator Bradley for
your testimony Mr chairman I I see that
representative oxenham has her hand
raised ah I see that too okay
representative oxum you you're
recognized for a
question thank you very much uh Mr chair
U Senator Bradley is it not the case
that the different classes were set up
in order to provide different incentives
for new renewable energy resources to
prioritize new resources over already
time frame so you know a dozen years ago
and at the time you're exactly right
um small scale Hydro
biomass um had been had had rate orders
for a long time in the you know
regulated world of of energy
production obviously those contracts
were bought out at the time but they
still existed and and um you know
had as you correctly note a lower
alternative compliance pay payment class
two being solar class one being anything
new um were given a greater incentive to
encourage more of that production but
we've seen significant increases in you
know that level of production so whether
the classes are collapsed into one class
which I think you know I would um want
to have the testimony of all of of the
solar the wind the um biomass and any of
the you know newer Technologies
hydrogen
um
thermal I'd want to know what the
consensus was amongst those folks before
making that judgment I think in
answering representative V's question
it's a good question and something that
you know may well want to be considered
in light of the fact where we are a
dozen years later ler but I think it's
important that um you folks and those of
us in the Senate if we're going to move
forward with that kind of an idea make
sure that amongst the providers there's
broad consensus for it I'm not sure that
now okay thank you Senator Bradley thank
you sir seeing no more
questions and um from the committee and
seeing no questions
from persons listening in as
attendees I guess at this point we can
close the public hearing on Senate Bill
113 thank you all very much and uh we
will uh take a five minute bio break and
then we
can I think I think we can legally start
the work session on Senate bill 78 even
though it's not scheduled on the
calendar until 11:00 since it's not a
public hearing or an exec session I
think you can start work sessions at any
time but I'll check that during the bio
break period and uh so we'll see you
you
John
well
for
EX
true
for
[Music]
what
for
okay everyone it's
10:45 I had proposed that we would
resume our activity at this time but
I've been informed that because we
published the time of 11 o'clock for the
work session on
sb78 we actually have to wait until 11
o'clock so it looks like you're going to
get another 15 minutes to rest your eyes
and we'll see you back here at 11
everyone
John
John representative C piss did you have
a comment oh I was gonna talk to John
and I we can I guess we can't talk to
scattered
are you planning representative vot are
May yes uh representative Cali pittz
thank you for the question I
representative Jackie is fine gets
Bor we you are going to plan another
yes we're definitely doing exec session
on May
I'm okay we will do that uh executive
session on May 24th and we'll have other
meetings as needed we have nothing else
coming over from the Senate we're done
we're
done the 10
o'clock start time again 10
o'clock
for
five
right
for
hello
happening uh 1:00 we're to talk about
minutes
e
okay everybody it is now 11 o'clock so
let us begin a work session on Senate
Bill
78 now Senate Bill 78 is actually a very
simple
Bill a bill that
uh wants to
restore the continuous appropriation of
money from the renewable energy
fund
that continuous appropriation was
removed by the house back in
and one of the members of the house
finance committee who participated in
that
activity was representative Lynn obber
and I invited her to come this morning
to our committee meeting to talk to us
about why the finance committee thought
it was necessary to remove that language
from the
statute this bill of course wants to
undo that 2017 action and restore the
language of the bill to its
original
form unfortunately representative obber
is not here yet
to discuss this with
us and what I'm going to attempt to do
this
basically what representative over said
was
that there could be a possibility of a
budget veto and as you'll recall there
was a budget
veto um in
201 18 I
believe and in the case of a budget veto
it's possible that um without this
language without the language that was
inserted in
2017 that the budget for the renewable
energy fund or the renewable energy fund
um
monies could
be spent without
legislative
Authority
so that was the reason that the
house
um made that change back in
if restoring the language that appeared
before 2017 was going to be a problem
and she said yes she said it could
happen again uh that if a budget gets
vetoed the house would have no control
over the spending um from the renewable
energy
fund
so there appears to be some reason for
continuing to do
this I was hoping that representative
obber would be here to explain it to you
but so far no
luck in the
meantime uh there are some other folks
who want to talk about this so let's
first start with representative McGee
thank you Mr chairman yeah from what you
I think that that was the year that
there was
um I
believe the reason they were looking at
this particular
Clause uh for RPS payments was because
there was another bill passed that was
giving uh the house back Authority for
oversight on on monies that were being
administered at the Pu so it seems to be
be this this ongoing conversation around
did we delegate responsibility where we
have oversight if we feel like we need
to pull something back do they have the
responsibility for the RPS funds or or
do we because they I thought that they
were acting as our agents in that in in
that when
um in this
example monies go into these funds
whether lapsing or non-lps and the way
this bill was explained to us I thought
was that they were saying based on the
fiscal year this money would then be
unavailable midy year for usage so that
programs that were in progress would
then have an empty budget line right the
money would be there but it would
unavailable they couldn't use it so I
don't I feel like it's us really gumming
up those works and so I I'm trying to
figure out I understand what represent
you know and I respect representative
obber I understand what you
explained
but where do we have a part in the
process if the funds are
non-aps right I mean because because
what it sounds like what you're saying
is if the budget is vetoed then we would
have no
say
um but in either case we don't have
they aren't they still administering
those funds I I I really wish you was
here to answer that question because it
doesn't make sense to me as
explained thank you representative McGee
I I share your confusion about this and
I'm sorry that representative obber is
not here I really uh expected that she
would be it's possible that the fiscal
committee has to
approve uh expenditures from the
renewable energy fund
I'm not certain about that I that's what
I was hoping reprentative Ober could CL
clarify for us but until she gets here
we'll just have to I think they said
that question they said recently that
that's going to go back in place next
year right that language that we saw
this year about either the house or the
fiscal committee had to
approve that language that we had in one
of our bills they were saying that even
if no matter what happened to that bill
as of next year um that process will be
in place for approvals of monies I I do
remember that does anybody else can
anybody help me out here okay well we'll
rate for representative Ober if
she shows up in the meantime
representative Cali pittz is recognized
for a
comment I I seem to realize or recall
that one year we had and I'm sure
representative V remembers this we had a
a quote unquote crisis and we needed to
take money from a dedicated fund now and
we had to have an emergency session of
the legislature to bring to come in to
authorize funds from for heating so a TR
a transfer and it had to be the
legislature so are we saying that the
RPS and the energy funds are not
dedicated
funds and when I looked at the report on
28 uh from 218 it said there was a
report on non-aps funds and I believe it
was over a million dollars so I'm I'm
not quite sure where this stands and
maybe the problem is that we don't
consider these dedicated funds do you
recall that incident with the heating
that we had to bring come in as an
emergency measure with the legislature
emergenc Merc session to authorize
expenditure of those dedicated funds for
rec excuse I can't I can't hear
you your voice was garbled Mr
chair oh I'm sorry I turned off my
microphone by accident um what I said
was I think that may happened before I
became a member of the legislature I
remember hearing talk about it but I
wasn't I remember not being around when
it actually
happened so once again representative
Ober could really help us if if we I
believe this is all in a quest to
protect our dedicated
funds and suspect you're right I suspect
you're
right we have not been
successful to date to protect those
funds okay let's uh let other folks have
pel yeah thank you Mr chairman just uh
reiterating on what uh representative uh
McGee already said these These
are funds they've it they're
non-lps so
whether they get to be used or not they
can't be used for anything else so it
just seems to
be there's more harm
done by uh not making them continuously
appropriated than the reverse which you
know I don't
know what uh what the
representative uh is is really trying to
prevent how big of an issue is it is
it it it's it may be an issue but I
don't know if it's such an issue that we
uh we gum up the
works all the other times which would be
year okay yeah thank you representative
ssuch is recomend for
comment thank you Mr chairman um if I
recall correctly uh Karen kampton from
the Pu testified on this and the way she
explained it was apparently
um if by a certain time point in the
year those funds are not expended even
though projects have been already uh U
begun under the assumption that monies
will be delivered later uh then that
money actually ends up sitting in that
fund um until the end of the year and uh
whatever isn't has not been
spent uh stays there
forever unless somebody does something
but it cannot be turned over into
funding in the next next year's uh
appropriation or or spending uh so in
other words a lot of businesses are out
there that have made commitments and the
customers that have signed contracts to
do things uh unless the paper work isn't
processed promptly enough will end up
having to wait as much as six months uh
for the next year's
Appropriations uh and in the meantime
there's a lot of dead Capital sitting in
that account that can't be spent on the
purposes for which it was intended so it
seems to me I think that we heard the
testimony I think a lot of us were kind
of shaking our heads to say this doesn't
make a lot of sense and I think Senator
Bradley underscored that that you know
this is money for that purpose so if
there is some issue with the finance
committee it seems to me we should be
able to find an Avenue where we can make
sure that those funds are spent for the
purpose they are dedicated and not to
hamper our businesses and our customer
and and residents of the state who have
engaged and signed contracts so this is
the purpose for that fund um it should
be predictable for everybody involved
and it helps our businesses and our
residents so I think whatever the the
the uh obstacles involved here I think
we should be able to find a a a solution
sides thank you representative uh next
don't forget to
unmute I just unmuted I hope um yes we
can hear you the um I think I'm agreeing
with uh what representativ some s
suggested I think we ought to be able to
invent some way to make it uh this
problem um impossible make it beo proof
or uh somehow
um uh preserve the dedicated use of the
fund to assigned for without um without
uh you know
legislative interference in other words
we obviously the legislature as a whole
could um change that for a specific case
but we should make it vetal proof and or
make it um
reliable somehow and I don't not being a
lawyer I have no idea how to do that
possible for example you could have pass
a law s requiring the legislative
approval in order to divert those funds
right okay thank you uh representative
oxenham is U is recognized for a comment
thank you Mr chair would it be possible
to ask madam minnow to uh weigh in on
this I think she has some technical
information that could help us with the
questions that were raised by
representative
obers absence is we left without the
knowledge actually I just got a text
from Karen krampton and she is
phone Miss kampton would be very helpful
as
well
I only see one one phone call here so
I'm gonna allow that person to talk I
hope that that's Karen cranon Miss
there
miss press star six to
phone there you go hi good morning this
is Karen kampton can you hear me yes we
can thank you oh good morning thank you
so um chairwoman Martin will be joining
shortly as well but um I think maybe if
I could take just a couple of minutes I
can explain uh the renewable energy fund
and what the non-line versus lapsing
language means along with the
continually
appropriated so uh would that be
acceptable chair
Rose um I don't know that there's much
disagreement amongst committee members
about about the the use of the renewable
energy fund or even whether it should be
non-aps and continually appropriated
continuously appropriated what we'd be
more interested in hearing is why the
finance committee thought it was
necessary to change the language back in
2017 do you have any
recollection no okay no I I I do not I
believe it was actually part of the
budget bill that HB 518 I believe was
rolled into the overall budget Bill and
that language was inserted but no I'm
sorry I don't have the history as to why
that was uh why that language was
inserted um I know that chairwoman
Martin did send a a letter along with
myself to the committee uh last week so
hopefully you have that it does give the
history at least of the amendment that
changed the language and it also
explains what happens at the end of the
fiscal year with any funds that remain
in the renewable energy fund that are
unspent and it tried to give an example
of the complications that that causes
when we have rebates um and other
incentives that need to get paid out
from this fiscal year funding with
monies that become
unaccessible to the commission uh at the
end of the fiscal year so that letter I
believe was to representative Harrington
along with um chairman
Bose was that letter not shared with the
entire
committee I you know uh chairwoman
Martin sent it but I believe she sent it
to everybody on St I I think it would
just addressed to to you two yeah yes I
I believe everybody in the committee had
a copy of that letter thank you so
chairman V this was my my question I had
the floor and I suggested that meline
minow could possibly help us and we went
to uh Miss Crampton could we possibly go
to miss minnow for for some insight as
to why that decision was made yes I was
just about to recognize Ms Mano oh thank
you so much I have allowed her to speak
and so I would ask her if she could
answer the question do you remember Miss
Mano why the finance committee thought
this was necessary to make this change
back in 2017 do you have any
recollection at all of that I can't
provide direct Insight on that change
unfortunately but um I would like to
speak to Dedicated funds and continuing
resolutions or budget
vetos um I have looked at quite a few
the RAS for quite a few other dedicated
funds and none of them contain special
Provisions or
restrictions on on them being um
continually appropriated in the case of
a budget veto or continuing resolution
so I did want to provide that
information that um it does not seem to
be something that is done to other
dedicated
funds very good that's very helpful we
appreciate you uh doing that research
and digging up that
information uh standby uh I'm going to
let you um stay here to answer
additional questions if you would and
Karen kampton you to as well happy to do
so right now I'm going to turn the floor
over to representative crean for a
comment or a
question thank you chairman um I just
had a very brief question um just
numbers wise does anyone have a sense of
how much money we're talking about um
rolling over or going into the the black
hole void not getting used uh each year
a million dollars miss kampton you want
to handle that
question certainly thank you chairman
Bose um so right now and it's it's an
Ever Changing amount but right now there
is um approximately for this fiscal year
spending so this fiscal year we were
allocated through the statement of
Appropriations approximately $5 million
for our budget we have approximately
right now $3 million that is unspent
when I say unspent what's important to
note is that we do have rebate
applications in house for projects that
are to be built which we would hope to
be able to fund with that money and
that's where we would traditionally
carry that that those funds over to the
next M year to pay those and we also
have two open rfps right now that we are
developing contracts for that we hope to
get through governor and Council by the
end of the year which would encumber
those funds or a portion of those funds
so yeah but about about $3 million I
would guess is on hand right now as
unspent thank you that kind of tip sorry
can I follow
up are you asking for a followup yes yes
go ahead I'm just wonder is that you
know typical from year to year
um yes I would say it's very typical
it's it's usually within the you know
anywhere from1 to5 million range and I
would say it very much depends on the
budget but it's typically two to three
million and that again are those rebate
applications that we receive in in the
spring where folks want to be able to
install renewable energy projects but
because of the building season those
projects don't end up getting built
until the end of the summer or or fall
time frame and that's when we would
actually release the funds to those
applicants that makes a lot of sense
thank you okay thank
you uh chair recognizes representative
comment I'm going to show my ignorance
here I did not understand uh your
representation what representative obor
said about the the budget and what
happens is does does these funds go
through the general fund and then get
allocated so so that they're dedicated
strictly for this purpose I'm not sure
what a budget has to do with anything
then uh so uh we may have to ask for
some input from representative obber
outside of this hearing uh and relay it
um because I just don't understand and I
wonder if there's some way to fix the
language here assuming A continuing
budget or with if a budget isn't passes
alternative action or something like
you okay thank you representative PL
next up would
be see who hasn't spoken yet uh
representative partial you're recognized
question yes thank you very much chair
uh Miss
Manel I I see it's part of our job to
enable your organization to spend the
money that we designate and this seems
like a roadblock being put up just
because our fiscal calendars are not in
alignment and that's is a matter of
curiosity if that's an incorrect
statement please correct
me
hear um I think maybe I'm not sure if
you're asking miss krampton our
organization does not have anything to
do with handling the renewable energy f
f um that the public utilities
commissions does I would agree that the
artificial construct of the FIS the
state fiscal year causing a major
disruption in the funding cycle is a
barrier to spending out these funds in
the way that the legislature directed
the Pu to
do in a way that would um you know it
just creates an artificial barrier and
Bureau ratic um hurdles to be able to
fulfill the direction that the
legislature gave in how to spend these
funds and do it consistently in a way
that's not disruptive well I guess this
would would count to a follow question
oh please go
ahead I was gonna say if I may this is
Karen krampton and I agree with what uh
meline Mano stated and I would say the
other thing that this does is it creates
some inefficiencies because we now have
to figure out how to handle these rebate
applications that come in in one fiscal
year but will not get built until
another fiscal year so there are
inefficiencies involved as
well thank you both you for your answers
my kind of followup I may or maybe my
question I was really driving at yes go
ahead uh do we have the same problem uh
existing on the federal level do you in
fact receive any monies from the federal
level and are they uh on a continuous or
elapsing basis
um not for renewable energy projects
there are some federal programs that are
managed by the office of strategic
initiatives like the weatherization
assistance program and fuel assistance
programs and I have to admit I am not uh
totally sure if if there are um
disruptions between one fiscal year to
the next in those
programs thank you m grampton and if I
may yes um thank you chairman um the
renewable energy fund is 100% funded
through alternative compliance payments
so they are payments paid by electricity
suppliers so there is no federal money
at all involved in these
programs thank you I have so much to
learn and thank you chair for taking my
question you're very
welcome uh representative Cali pittz
you're up next yeah I think I just want
to
um speak to 78 and condense it down to
get out of the weeds this is simply a
bill to avoid a money grab should
something happen to the budget when when
we don't have a budget then you have to
go flying around looking for money this
if those funds are continuously
appropriated means that I believe that
they can't stick their hand in the
cookie
jar meaning us and pull that money out
and use it for something else as I said
in the very beginning I think it's a
move to protect this dedicated fund
which I believe is correct so I I find
nothing wrong with this bill and I think
that as a measure if it's a if it's a
Band-Aid or a little bit of safety
thinking that we may not have a
budget uh I think we should just go
ahead and move on with it that's all it
is it's to prevent a money grab it's
nothing more it's nothing
less representative Cali pittz those are
very insightful comments and um it well
they they're to the point they're New
York comments let's stop beating about
the bush and say what it is it helps me
understand now I believe why
representative
obber um Wanted the language that that
currently exists to be in the bill so
that the legislature would have the
option if a budget got
vetoed of finding another source of
money to spend on something if it needed
to if it needed to and and I think if I
may chairman yes go ahead I think that
you know we have too long been
collecting money for one
thing and then using it for another and
I think energy is very important right
now and the money that people are paying
into this fund should not be quote
unquote robbed because we're in a fiscal
crisis I do believe that the legislature
can always come in as a legislature not
as three people as a legislature and say
we need this money for this and this is
an emergency measure we've done it
before and I don't know what the
Situation's going to be this winter you
know with the price of oil going up the
way it is and and with people struggling
what are we going to need but I believe
that's the purview of the legislature as
a whole not just it okay we got two
million3 million sitting over here let's
grab it that that's wrong to me so I
think this bill is well worth it at this
time because I think we're in a
precarious time I don't know about
anybody else but I I'm I'm believing
we're probably not going to get a budget
so
okay so if your theory is correct
then if the legislator needed
legislature needed some additional money
because a budget got
vetoed we have like a hundred million
rainy day fund correct that we can get
money from we have milon in this fund
would be a drop in the bucket compared
to that we have many sources where we
can get money from but a source like
this this is very lwh hanging fruit boom
you can pull it out and and I think you
know it's there it's like tempting it's
like the candy sitting on the on the
table I'm G to go eat it I think it's
there and you can grab it um and we've
done it before and you know you figure
what what would $3 million do say to
heating assistance would be a lot it
would go a long way so I think we need
to uh protect this money knowing that
it's always there if the entire
legislature wants or has to do something
with it but I think we need to protect
it for the purpose for which it was
me can anyone Envision a situation in
which the legislature would be so
desperate for
money that it would have to come after
this $3 million can anybody Envision
that yes they did it in 2013 we've done
it before
once it happened
once and we are in a series of unknowns
right now we don't know what's going to
happen uh I if heating oil would go up
to $4 a gallon what's going to happen
we're gonna start scrambling and and I
think we have
to
understand I don't know I in my mind I
want to protect what this was meant for
and yes the the leg legislature has
scrambled before and yes we've done it
before was it necessary when we did it
yes it was but I think that's up to the
legislature to decide not just for
somebody to look over and say well well
there's a nice pot of money let's take
it because they're not using
it I think our fiscal picture is pretty
healthy right now representative pimel
comment oh I guess I'm off mute already
um m I actually have a question for uh
Miss Crampton and that concerns
procedure I'm curious
when as being someone in the building
trade I I I
remember these monies really were time
sensitive as far as when projects would
start and when they would have to end
and all that sort of thing and I'm just
curious if someone is uh approve for a
produ project and they don't complete it
by the end of the fiscal
year
um I my guess is that they would not be
able to get what has been promised then
until the next fiscal year and the
question is do they have to reapply for
it the next fiscal year or is it
automatically going to come to them but
they have to wait until the money is
allocated at a certain date whether it's
six months in the future or a year in
the
future Miss grampton
yes thank you chairman go and thank you
for the question um it's a little bit
difficult to answer that question right
now I can tell you that what your
stating is correct if somebody send a
rebate application on this fiscal year
but their project was not built and we
did not receive what we call a step two
payment application by June 30th um we
would not be able to use this year's
fiscal funding to pay that rebate so
then yes the funds are in question and
it would be a commissioner level
decision as to whether or not um re
application would be required or whether
or not they would choose
to
um allow this fiscal Year's applications
to be paid with next next fiscal Year's
money
um so that would be a decision that
would need to be made the other thing
that I will mention is we are still
working with the Department of Justice
to figure out ways of um handling this
situation so so that explanation could
change but the way it is today because
these funds are not continually
appropriated the monies available this
fiscal year will not be available to pay
1st thank you thank you thank you
representative parall you have your hand
up do you have another question no okay
uh does anyone else have h a question
representative ssuch you have a
question uh thank thank you Mr chairman
and thank you Miss krampton
so ju just to clarify what you just said
apparently in some cases something as
simple as a contract that's already been
proposed and not quite completed
requires that it be kicked up to the
commissioner level to make a decision is
that
correct Miss
Granton yes thank you chairman um for
rebate level applications yes that would
be correct and it would not be a one by
one decision I think it would be an
overall budget decision and they
actually um had to rule on this this
previous fiscal year where we did not
have the continually appropriated funds
they did Issue an order or a secretary a
letter directing staff to use this
year's fiscal funding to pay last year's
rebat now there is a distinction because
you said contracts and and that's very
important to know that all of our
contracts still Rec require have always
required governor and Council approval
so and any any contracts that are
approved by governor and Council those
funds are encumbered and once some is
encumbered once funds are encumbered
they are available for use in future
fiscal years for that specific contract
so our larger projects are okay it's
really the rebate programs that are
caught in this um uh transitional
conern thank you thank you very much
thank you representative oxam you have a
question or a comment yes thank you very
much um
it trying trying to to pull this
together uh it it seems that the
situation that we have at the moment is
the result of the finance committee not
understanding the peculiarities of the
renewable energy fund there's no other
fund to my knowledge that in under the
state control of New Hampshire where you
have a small group of people who pay in
um you know it it's it's these are DED
they're they're dedicated from the
moment they leave the utilities and they
go into that fund they are there for one
purpose and one purpose only which was
established by the legislature they are
to be used to finance renewable energy
projects so the notion that we need to
be you know worrying about this
happening or that happening um in the
case of a budget that isn't approved it
it it's it's just an extraordinary
situation and I think that what we need
to do is clarify this as Jackie cell pit
suggested representative Cali pittz that
we take the option available to us and
promote this bill and go forward with it
because it solves really a a
non-existing but the new language that
was created by the finance committee
created a problem that problem is an
obstacle what we need to do is go back
to the way it was pass this bill so that
we don't have these problems in the
future we're not going to solve the
problem of raids on dedic ated funds the
legislature has always rated dedicated
funds and and that's just that's a side
issue we need to concentrate on what's
us okay thank you representative oxenham
comment seeing none I would like to
thank Miss krampton from the Pu and M
Mano for being available to answer our
questions and um I think we all have a
pretty good sense that this bill should
go forward um so I think we can expect
that that should happen at exec session
time so as I explained at the beginning
of our session here earlier
today we're going to have exec session
on this
bill on May 24th that's a Monday so make
plans accordingly if you're not going to
be here to vote on the bill make
arrangements through your caucus to have
substitute appear in your
place so that uh your voice can be
heard and um we will also be executing
on that day Senate Bill
91 now we're going to be having a work
session on Senate Bill 91 starting at
one o'clock this afternoon that piic
bill as you'll recall has four sections
to it what we're going to do is we're
going to go through section
one and talk about some language changes
that may need to be made in section one
when we had the public hearing on that
bill Senator Waters who was its primary
sponsor indicated there were several
places in the bill where he thought some
language changes were appropriate
so we will discuss that first in our
work session starting at
1:00 sections two and sections three of
the bill will'll discuss if need be I
think uh they're pretty straightforward
and may not require much
discussion and then we'll close the uh
work session with a extend extensive
discussion of section
four I sent earlier this morning some
proposed amendment text for section four
that resolves three significant issues
with that section of the bill so we'll
have a lengthy discussion of that
Clifton Belo will be here to answer
questions on that particular proposed
language much of which he authored
himself um
so I I hope you'll all be here for that
discussion on Senate Bill 91 at one
clock representative plet recognized for
a question yes I I did think there was a
section five still in the bill and there
intent maybe to pull it but it hasn't
been pulled right is that
correct yes thank you for that reminder
there is a section five in the bill and
we will be uh during the amendment
process removing that section from the
bill because House Bill 315 which we
passed and has been sent to the Senate
uh is the complete solution to that
problem so we don't need section five of
sp91 all right so before we break for
lunch does anybody have anything to uh
committee representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to ask if the folks from my
caucus on the call could uh could look
for a uh Zoom link from me so that we
lunch that's all okay representative
ssuch uh yes uh thank you Mr chairman uh
I just wanted to bring up the question
of the Department of energy um as I
mentioned to you uh previously it I
think it would be very helpful if we
could uh arrange for some kind of a
briefing of this committee uh regarding
the plans or the proposed plans for the
Department of energy um this would be
the right committee to have something
like
that yes I 100% agree with you
representative ssuch in the tenative
plan and it still hasn't
been confirmed but the tenative plan is
to have a presentation on the new
Department of energy after our exec
session on May
24th thank you Mr
chairman
does anyone else have anything uh to
bring before the committee before we
lunch seeing
none I'll call this work session
completed for now and H ask everyone to
enjoy your lunch and please return at
much
pass
working
a
did anybody know Larry
bartl oh he just put something on his
um his profile pictur I got
is good afternoon everybody it's now one
o'clock and I'm going to delay just for
a couple of minutes the resumption of
our work session just to let everybody
get back
by
representative V this is Gen 4 um I I'm
sure you got my message earlier but I
have uh Brad Greenland stepping in if
you guys have any problems he'll be on
the line um while I go to my appointment
this
afternoon okay thank you Jen good luck
with your vaccination
thanks and welcome
Brad
those
okay I guess we'll get started now I'd
like to formally open the work session
on Senate Bill
and I look forward to
a productive if somewhat lengthy
conversation about this legislation as
you know it had five parts when it
arrived here from the
Senate part one is relative to the
installation
interconnection and use of energy
utilities
first we will discuss part two and three
briefly if
needed and then we will discuss part
four at
length part five we will not discuss
because that part of the bill we plan to
delete from this legislation and that
action was approved by all of the spons
one I hope you all have a copy of the
legislation in front of
you what I would like to do is go
through the
legislation and highlight some issues
that I see with the wording of the
legislation and then discuss with all of
you potential corrections to said
[Music]
wording so the
first area that I see that could use
some
work is on page one of the
30 there's a sentence that reads such a
program shall compensate participating
behind the meter energy storage for a
fair
share as determined by the commission
well is it fair to use the word words of
the of the legislation for us to give
the commission such a
vague
uh definition as fair share what is a
fair
share um it seems to me that it would be
much more useful to the commission if we
gave them some kind
[Music]
of
numeric indication of what a fair share
might be or tighten up that language
somehow fair share just doesn't seem to
me to
be an adequate definition for the
commission to
use I'm not even sure exactly what the
original authors
intended when they said fair share
so I'd like to know uh who else on the
committee might have an opinion about a
what fair share means and B what's a
more precise way to define it for the
Public Utilities Commission
representative McGee what do you think
yeah thanks I I actually um when I read
the sentence and the sentence before it
it appears to me that we're asking them
to determine what a reasonable
compensation is fair share I think is is
referring to you know how do we um Rumer
them or compensate them for the value
that they're bringing to the system but
I agree with you I mean I'm not sure it
needs to be spelled out in numbers
because it would be changing it would be
transitory they would have to continue
to update it I would imagine if we put
numbers in there but in the prior
sentence on
29 uh the leadin says um value to the
electricity system particularly in terms
of peak reduction and avoided
transmission and distribution costs so
it's asking the commission to make a
calculation based on those things which
are kind of moving targets so I don't I
don't know I don't know if I agree that
we need to give them a nu numeric
guidance but maybe we need to be more
specific about
um the language to your
point um so I I think what it's saying
is a uh reasonable
compensation
um I speak I'm I'm unfortunately on a
telephone
yep who's that represent Mr
CH thank you very
much okay yes representative
oxam thank you uh this language was
agreed to when um HB 715 went to the
Senate last year and it was put in at
the behest of the Republicans on the
senate committee because they felt that
they wanted to ensure as you have many
times um adjured us to ensure that there
was no possibility of a cost shift um
the the republ Senate Republicans felt
that this language um accomplish that it
needs to be read in concert with the
language at the top of Page Three which
is e uh concerning uh bring your own
devices um and it's a little bit it's
spelled out OS doesn't let us spell
things out twice you have to spell it
out once and then a different provision
will refer back to another provision so
this is the clarification because this
is where behind the meter um bod is is
discussed and so it says the commission
may approve approve mechanisms to
compensate projects for a fair share as
determined by the commission so it's a
fair share of their Peak reduction value
as well as any transmission or
distribution costs actually avoided and
that actually avoided language means it
has to be demonstrated that money was
you know they they had a bid on this
system it would have been five million
they had a bid on the other system it
was 3 million that demonstrates a cost
Savings of $2 million so that would be
working I hope that helps okay so how
would it uh how would this modification
to that sentence work such a program
shall compensate participating behindth
meter energy
storage for the value it provides to the
commission any reaction to that
language I'm doing my best um
unfortunately I have backed a front
print out here very difficult to compare
the two side by side um I know that when
I checked into this I was directed to
look at the language at the top of Page
Three and uh that that
is that's the language that was pointed
out again it was a compromise uh that
was agreed to in the S this is not a
change that is being produced in this
this is not new this is um
legislation I can't so in section
representative representative Bernardi
is recognized for a comment thank you
chairman I I like uh if you're going to
say strike a fair share and substitute
the value it actually provides I think
that makes sense and I would also note
that this fair share bad language also
occurs on line 37 of the second
page yes the Senate Republicans liked
that language Republicans do not like
like fair share it has never been a
republican
position unfair not that we want unfair
but no one ever wants to say what a fair
is that's correct we're not discussing
tax
rates okay such a program shall
compensate participating behind the
meter energy storage
for the value it actually provides to
the electricity system as determined by
the
commission that sound
reason may I point out um in nine D and
E there's language that says that costs
actually avoided could we just replicate
that at the top for consistency or does
it need to be different could you point
out the line numbers um for me I'm
looking unfortunately at the the web
version but it's in part one Roman
n
PDF it it's it's also on top of Page
Three line six actually avoided costs
actually avoided I I agree I think
that's better than
fair share I mean it it says both but
yes okay I think we've got that changed
down
then now on page
23 when he testified on this bill
representative Clifton
Belo suggested that we add some
language to line 23 that says that ISO
England May operate pursuant to RSA and
then he cited an RSA does anybody have
in their notes the number of the actual
RSA he
cited could you repeat the page number
that line 23 to which you're referring
if we don't have the answer to that
question uh The Honorable Clifton voo
will be with us in a little while we can
time I I have a question Mr chairman I
think we moved kind of quickly over the
actual language um I think we might be
um I think we might be changing the
meaning of some of the language that was
here by avoiding the words fair share as
they were intended here because I think
what fair share is supposed to
encapsulate is the actual avoided Cost
Plus other value including um Peak
reduction because when you look at the
list of stuff that's that's calculated
here it seems as though the public
utility commission is going to have to
do a calculation to determine those
costs and they will not all be actual
avoided costs they will be avoided costs
and
other uh reductions based on the fact
that we're not incurring that load so
there will be another way that they will
have to calculate it and that's why I
think they were using that language
specifically because actual avoided
costs is a
subset of what they're calculating it's
just I'm just throwing that out there I
could be wrong but when I'm reading this
it sounds like it's a little more
complicated and that's why they were
using a you know like a placeholder of
saying that they have to figure out the
fair share that uh should be alloted for
that
value so I just want to make sure that
makes undoing that makes a lot of sense
yeah I just don't want to undo what it
is that they're intending and maybe we
should figure that out before we sarily
change it because it sounds sounds like
they were trying to figure out a way to
accommodate the
reality and perhaps Senator Bradley
could help us with that if
yeah well The Language Fair
Share just doesn't
sound definitive enough to be useful by
the commission
so that language has got to go Mr
chairman in the in the sentence above
you've defined representative plat yes
Mr chairman yeah could we say uh
something like for all costs actually
avoided I mean I that's to me it's
comprehensive it doesn't have to be just
T and whoever is
avoided that's a reasonable suggestion
representative Bernardi yes thank you Mr
chairman you you use the term value it
actually provides and value to me is
describing Peak reduction avoided costs
avoided distribution cost you're looking
at all of those things in the sentence
above to determine a value so I think I
think the language that you initially
struck is makes
sense okay thank you I I do think we
need to follow this up um and pursue it
because
there well I've discussed I don't think
we I've discussed all these changes with
Senator Waters and he was in agreement
with most of them so uh I will run these
changes by him again before we um
proceed to the amendment drafting stage
there the next issue that I would uh
like to address is also on page
two Mr chairman I've got my hand
raised did someone say something yes
this is um Peter ssuch have my hand
raised uh sorry representative ssuch I
didn't see that go ahead thank you um I
I just wanted to point out that it would
be important to clarify this issue with
the fair share because like represent
oxam pointed out at the top of Page
Three the paragraph e that says for
behind the meter storage again they use
the term fair share and then go on to
actually avoid it so great apparently
this this term comes up often so it
might have more meaning than we think so
this
okay representative crean did you have a
a point to make here no okay all right
so the next issue to resolve is on page
two starting at line 30 and running
through line
it says New Hampshire's consumer
consumers of electricity have a right to
install interconnect and use energy
storage systems on their property
subject to appropriate size and safety
requirements established by the
commission without the burden of
unnecessary restrictions or regulations
and without unduly
discriminatory rates or
fees now this paragraph to me seems to
take away way local control as someone
who serves on a planning board in my
community I don't think it would be uh
appropriate for someone to install an
energy storage system on their
property that violated local zoning
ordinances for example but this
paragraph would seem to indicate
that a local planning board wouldn't be
able to make a decision about
such a sighting so I'm uh wondering if
it might be necessary to delete this
paragraph or this sentence Al
together
um could you representative
flat not only is your point about local
zoning uh right on the money but also
this take seems to take away from the
local utility the uh any uh interconnect
requirements they might have to make a
safe system this language would say you
can put up what anything you want if it
doesn't interconnect with utility too
bad so sad so again I think it worth is
worth
striking well it does say that it's
subject to appropriate size and safety
requirements established by the
commission so one would assume that U
that would have been done in conjunction
with
utilities but larger question here is
does this
paragraph abgate or remove local control
from local communities can you say can
anybody hear me I I'm trying to go
between two screens and it's like
ridiculous we can hear I haven't called
on you so representative Bernardi has
the floor yes uh thank I agree that this
language as written agregates local
zoning uh uh Authority and so we can
either eliminate it or alternatively add
that uh that the uh installation must
requirements representative Jackie C
pittz I can't see anybody well that I
think that an ad would be just after
going through the commission and local
uh permitting process whatever that may
be
you know there are several Le layers in
many in many committies historic
districts and so I think the add local
permitting process would be
simple so that the commission first is
going to say it's so it it's it fits the
needs and it's going to interconnect
properly Etc and then local permitting
process so how about if we just added to
the end of the sentence yeah uh
without unduly discriminatory rates or
fees comma and must conform to local
zoning and per permitting requirements
yeah and in accordance with local yeah
that's just simple yeah and that way
it's up to the local towns to add zoning
ordinances
needs okay I like that
I think that will satisfy the
requirement that local permitting and
Zoning is
um is being adhered
[Music]
to
okay so that takes care of that
concern I do have my hand
oxum you have the floor Rec repres
representative
oxam yes can you hear me now yes thank
you very much I just wanted to point out
that this is in fact new language being
this is part of the new bill this is
Senator waters's language and if you
have in fact had success speaking with
him about changes to his language then
that should pass muster with
him yes maybe when I explained that I
would be running all these changes
Senator
Waters that's that was my point new
material okay thank you next question is
on line S uh
35 the last three words in that sentence
affordable for customers does that need
to be
defined
yes so we're talking here
rules utility approval processes and any
required interconnection reviews of
energy storage systems shall be simple
customers what is the definition of
affordable for
customers is that something that the Pu
can easily determine during a rules
making
process not unreasonable or in line with
processes I didn't quite understand what
what you said
representative is is there something
that we could reference to like are
there other approval processes that
might we might be able to say in line
how about if we just reasonable
affordable cost effective for
who customers for customers yeah but
what is the consu when when the when the
Pu makes a decision don't they make it
in the best interests of instead of
affordable or because affordable is very
different depending on who you talk
well what's affordable for me might not
be affordable for you that's exactly
right so don't they do the best
interests of the customers when they
consumer Advocate makes a decision
case well it's a it's a good question
anybody have any thoughts about
Marshall yes thank thank you uh chair I
I'm reading that is that it's not going
to be an extra hurdle for the customer
to get through right affordable I mean
we're putting a system in to begin with
and they'll have to determine the cost
of putting that system in I think what
this bill is trying to say is that or
this this section is simple
streamlined and not Bure
bureaucratically weighed down and
because every system is going to be
different as far as figuring how to
interconnect it I would imagine I think
what they're trying to do is avoid a
bureaucratic hurdle on behalf of the
customer and how to put that in language
I'm relying on your experience but I
don't think it's anything more than that
I would
say
agree well the section that this falls
under
is rules that the Public Utility
Commission is going to make or
adopt to clarify policy for the for
installation and use of these energy
storage systems
and paragraph C is specifically talking
about the utility approval process right
and interconnection reviews of energy
storage systems
so basically it it
says this par this this sentence says
that the utility approval process must
be simple streamlined and affordable for
customers
but can the public ities commission
dictate to the utility what's affordable
and what's not that I guess that would
be my
question I think having this have
a thank you uh Mr chairman yes so
earlier this year we reviewed bills with
had to head fees for the sighting
Authority and remember we reduced the
fee for for one particular kind of
interaction with the sighting Authority
when a when a uh uh a local citizen
wanted to get an anybody of whether or
not and the uh things were going in
accordance with the license
requirements um but the fees were all
set in that particular legislation I I
think what this requires is you you
define a fee for this kind of service it
is X number of dollars this this this
[Music]
unacceptable um
so how about if we substitute the
language that
[Music]
said utility approval processes and any
required interconnection reviews of
systems
[Music]
shall
be
determined I'm thinking out loud here
work Mr chairman would I would I i'
would like to suggest that uh this this
word might be like
pornography you you will know when it's
not affordable I mean it's you
know people can see when something is
orous and trying to be an obstacle but
it's very hard to determine exactly
where that level is but uh I I think
people will know if it's very
obstructive financially that that's not
affordable so I don't know if we can
really Define it better than that King
chairman V could I say something uh
representative FAL yes thank you
chairman Vose I I think that uh
representative C Pitts really hit it on
nail what what they're looking for is is
something that is Affordable I mean they
specifically say
customers and I think that saying in the
best interests of
customers it's not it really works well
I think it it uh it means that they have
to look when they're doing it they have
to look at the customer to to determine
whether or not it's fair so just that
language it's very simple and it just
directs them that the uh customer is
also part of the
equation may I speak Mr chair yes
representative oxam go ahead thank you
very much this section is what uh
Senator Waters called the energy storage
Bill of Rights so so it's it's a little
bit on I'm almost want to say the
flowery side but what he's trying to get
at here is what I think many people on
his side of the aisle are concerned with
that there should be policy direction
for the Pu that we that that they should
not be making it up as they go along but
the legislature should go on record and
saying this is how we want you to do
this sort of thing not micromanage but
give them some policy Direction
um so cost effective
affordable it it's it's it's generic but
it does it points in the direction of
be uh what how about how about cost
effective for all
parties
well I guess would speak up up like
everybody else has because I've had my
hand up for a while can I can I say
something yeah go ahead thanks um
so um taking what everyone has said so
far um this being listed under the
guidelines that we're trying to give the
Public Utilities Commission for customer
energy storage systems I think it makes
sense as is written or um because it is
guidance for the public Utilities
Commission but um to the point that was
made earlier about
us lowering a fee for the site
evaluation committee which is a separate
entity that would not apply here because
this particular bullet applies to the
utilities and we don't we don't wasn't
the point yeah yeah but but what I'm
saying is we don't we can't put into
statute what that affordability of what
the utility is going to charge but the
Public Utilities Commission
does have the relationship where they
actually would intercede if they thought
the utilities were making it too onerous
to another point that was made earlier
for customers to be able to do storage
in their own homes in their you know
have have their own physical facilities
so I mean I I I don't feel strongly one
way or another about the affordable for
customers I think is probably sufficient
guidance for the Public Utilities
Commission because their role is to make
sure that that they're serving the
interests of the public which means the
rate payers so they're the Arbiter
between what the how the utility is
administering the statutes and the way
the customers end up being charged for
it so I I don't know that we wouldn't
just be pie in the skying making things
up in terms of they have a process for
figuring out what's reasonable or
affordable so I I don't know how much
more specific the language can be
because we don't have that process I
don't think I'm I'm going to I can't say
and I'm I apologize for that because I
have to look at the bill I haven't got a
printer working so I'm I'm in the blind
here but the I don't think the Pu ever
goes
on what's
affordable I think the premise that they
use and I hope it is is just and
reasonable and in the best interest I
don't think they can decide what's
affordable because if you go down to the
next paragraph it talks about how we can
you know how we're going to reimburse
people for doing this yeah um and I
think
that that's where that's where the
problem comes in because if I reimburse
you at a higher a much higher rate for
this
storage which isn't for your own use in
case there's a blackout it's it's a sell
back to the grid let's face it
then it may not
be in the best interest of all the
customers and it may not be just and
when they say customers it's not just to
my mind the guy who's putting it up and
the guy who's buying it it's everybody
right who's affected by it the entire
state so I would hope they use adjust
and reasonable and I think they do that
when they do a rate case somebody puts
in for a 20% raise they're going to wait
a minute whoa um and then they have to
you know figure that all out which is
way beyond my paygrade but I think that
you know affordable is such a term that
is
not you know to me an orange isn't
affordable at a buck a piece
okay I I
don't but to somebody else a case may be
very affordable so I think that
affordable term is really out of whack
there but it's modifying the utility
approval process right so it's saying
what the utilities are charging people
in order to get them through the process
of being able to have storage at their
place is supposed to be
simple simple streamlined and it should
be just and reasonable yeah I I I can
understand that I can and I can live
with that I think that that that makes
sense if if a if affordable is language
that really doesn't mean what people are
trying to say then we should change it
so I I don't know if Justin reasonable
is is a is a good compromise but I think
that's what it should be because you're
going to take into the transmission and
all you know they're going to have to
hook up to there's all kinds of costs
and I think
that that's where they have to come back
to the commission and say well this is
what we're charging and the commission
comes back and say that's not that's not
just and reasonable according to you
know oil here I I don't know yes
reasonable for all parties too not just
for the the purchasing parties but also
for the utilities who have to do
interconnection of these well and and
that would be for all the customers
because then they would be a customer
right exactly so for all customers just
and reasonable for all customers and I
thing language for that
line so we we move down to line 37 once
again we have the ambiguous term fair
share so I think we should uh rewrite
that to reflect the language of actual
avoided
commission
good yeah I think
that's uh Mr chair we we disagreed on
that when you brought it up previously
ly under representative McGee made the
point that the that they're two
different things the fair share and the
actually avoided cost one is a subset of
the other again we're getting into the
issue of what what is the value of these
systems having more energy storage in
New Hampshire is a value to everyone in
New Hampshire we reduce costs and and it
flows to the system it's there are the
things that are actually
we that they that are determinable the
way that I gave the previous example
about the five million and the three
million and the two million and there
other things that are not so readily
available but the commission recognizes
that they provide a value to the system
and they we want that to encourage them
to do that because it's a benefit to
everyone in the system that we have more
reliability more resiliency and are able
to to to go forward with
that Mr chair okay so moving on to page
three Mr chair I I would go back
representative Bernardi thank you Mr
chair I think the agreement that we came
to was that the fair share should be the
value it actually provides and value
then encompasses all the things that
represent roxham and everybody else is
talking
about yes I agree with that I think I do
too so the if you move to page three we
once again
have uh that ambiguous language on line
five fair share so we'll replace that
with the agree to language of
value Mr chair I just get clarification
yes uh representative
crean uned myself um so can I just
clarify we're keeping fair share but
then modifying it to clarify or you're
eliminating fair share entirely no the
the phrase a fair share will be replaced
in every instance where it is found in
this legislation by language to
indicate uh that what we mean is actual
avoided costs
oh no actually avoided cost is not the
ter value is greater value provided was
the term
right but is it fair to ask the Public
Utilities Commission to try to come up
with a
value uh for something that's not
avoided
costs that's what they've been doing in
their their studies on the value of
solar and the value of distributed
energy
yeah but this par paragraph here talks
specifically about Peak reduction
values and transmission or distribution
cost actually
avoided that kind of
[Music]
thing yes representative
PL yeah I think we're talking some
Antics because to me actual avoided cost
would include any value coming from Peak
reduction but you can't invent value
it's it's you got to demonstrate that
there value to the system not only in
reduced transmission and distribution
but also in in in provid to the
system I I'm afraid that was very
garbled at the end we couldn't
understand what representative PL
said maybe the microphone not quite so
close to your
mouth no you're too close for the ACT
avoided cost I think it's it's a prop
components can argue to the commission
that that close vo reduction in
transmission and distribution but also
storage you're too close to the mic it's
all
said so basically representative pl's
point was that actual avoided costs can
values it's not just uh the actual
transmission or distribution costs that
are actually
avoided but I think if you put the
language in that it has to
be
exclusively avoided
costs there may be other aspects of the
value calculation that you cannot then
include so I think the language is
exclusionary and that makes it wrong the
other way like in other words we had
language that was too vague but now
we're having language that's that's
insisting that if there are other
aspects of value that do not come down
to actual
avoided they won't be calculated list
we'd have to enumerate what those other
values
[Music]
were well perhaps we can work on that I
thought if if I could I did I read
somewhere that Capital costs or whatever
could not be included in this value
situation repeat that question when you
are reimbursing somebody or figuring out
the value that you could not include
Capital costs in other words if it cost
me $40 to build this transmission thing
I can't include that in what the value
of it is did I read that or is that in
another
bill the capital cost could not be
included well this bill doesn't talk
about Capital costs at all I know but it
in the value when you talk about the
value of
something
um the construction of of it on its own
would have value wouldn't it the value
that this bill talks about is mostly the
value that it sees avoided transmission
and distribution costs right and Eric
Johnson of iso New England testified
before this committee a couple of weeks
ago few weeks ago don't remember exactly
when it was that ISO in New England sees
no avoided transmission costs no I don't
see any either connect to the grid they
don't have the uh equipment to see
avoided transmission costs but he said
they don't see any so
uh calculating avoided transmission
costs
is a difficult process and we'll learn
more about that in about a half an hour
or whenever we get to it when we talk
about section four of this bill because
that it becomes an
important almost crucial aspect of
section four of Senate Bill
91 Mr chair it it really is awfully
important that people get a chance to to
get in
where if if I may go forward I know
others have their hands up as well yeah
continue on thank you very much um the
issue of capital costs take an example
you could build a substation or you
could install battery storage those
either one of those are going to be
Capital costs so you are certainly going
to be including Capital costs in this
comparison but the issue two years ago I
believe it was when we were first
looking at energy storage we had a panel
that came in we had three people who
presented we had those charts about the
value stack there are many many values
they talked about energy storage as a
Swiss army knife we don't if if we only
include the
minimal we are not going to get the
maximum value energy storage provides
enormous value and I I beg to differ
about what Eric Johnson said I had I
have in my notes that later in the
meeting when we were discussing the
difference between what Dees had told us
and what what he was saying for ISO he
agreed that there were opportunities for
such savings so um this is complicated
it's very difficult to word Smith um via
Zoom but I think we we at we
cannot really this if if we change this
language to avoid a gos cost we have
gutted the bill this this is the
probably the most significant section in
the bill and the point of providing an
opportunity for all the values provided
to be counted is the only way in which
you're going to
get
incentivize and have produced and
installed the the single most valuable
technology we have that takes
intermittent distributed resources and
makes them
available at times when they're not
producing it this is so
important that's why we have a pu
proceeding on this right
now okay thank you representative repres
representative crean did you have
another comment you wanted to
make no I'm sorry I keep forgetting to
put my hand down representative uh McGee
thank you Mr chairman yeah um I just
want I just had a comment on what you
mentioned about the iso and it's it's a
little bit tangential but just so folks
can be aware there's a settlement
agreement that's just about completed um
over at the Public Utilities Commission
on the Statewide energy data platform
and the whole point of having
um a software tool that would allow us
to uh see the distributed energy
resources behind the meter we don't have
that view at this point so we can't see
those assets because they're not on the
system in terms of iso's calculations
and I think that's one of the reasons
that our speaker from ISO made that
point because they don't they don't
count the value of those assets because
they can't see them they can't count
them we're going to be putting in a a
tool that will allow us to see the
behind the meter resources and manage
them so the value again of what it will
mean for us to have our own local uh
sustainable generation sources is
something that we will have more
insights into and more ability to
calculate their value we don't have that
data right now because we have no way to
do it and and a lot of other states are
in the same
uh place so I think New Hampshire's done
a good job of kind of getting ahead of
it um and so I just wanted to mention
that because it is related um that we
have a very limited ability right now to
understand what kind of value these
these generation assets play okay thank
you handle on it okay we got the point
okay all right so
um the other area of the bill that I
just think needs a little language tweak
is on page
25 which says electric generation
equipment in this chapter shall exclude
equipment that sentence is technically
incorrect so I propose that we uh change
the language to
chapter shall not include storage energy
storage equipment for sales
purposes otherwise we enshrine in law a
definition that's actually
incorrect
so with the with the help of legislative
Services I'm sure we can fix this line
so that it doesn't actually State
something that's
[Music]
technical Mr chair this issue of the
definition has come up again and again
when dealing with energy storage and
what they're saying is for this chapter
for this purpose it shall be excluded
they're not trying to change the
definition elsewhere but there's a
reason for this and it has to do with
how energy storage equipment is
restricted in other rsas that this is
simply a clarification that in this
particular chapter this term shall not
include energy storage it again it it it
it it's much more important than it
appears to
be okay well I'm sure we can find a way
to State this that um States what what
you're getting at and I understand
that's what it's trying to get at that's
why I said as generation for sales
purposes but fores a definition that's
incorrect yes but you're introducing for
sales purposes and that that wording is
is not here and it is not I don't
believe is
Germain and it and it could introduce
problems with other statutes that's why
I suggested that OS will be able to help
us come up with the the precise language
we need here once they understand the
concept well but they're not regul
Energy Regulatory lawyers and they may
not understand the situation but I I
think we do need they are at it further
they are professional legislation
drafters
so yes Jacks of all trade and very good
at their jobs they are they are
indeed can I can I ask a clarifying
question on that definition there so
electric generation equipment quote in
this chapter shall exclude are they
trying to exclude them be storage assets
because they're load reducing versus
generating is that the is that
the distinction they're trying to make
here maybe adding the word exclude load
reducing energy storage equipment no
because mine minnow available to us at
this point she might be able to answer
that question correct
you know a battery is an electrical
generation a piece of electrical
generation equipment a battery doesn't
store electricity a battery is a
chemical mechanical and chemical system
that actually generates electricity no
as
uh the chemical process inside the
battery uh moves forward it transforms
it it doesn't create you have to charge
a battery
right all that does is reverse the
chemical process so that the chemical
process can happen again but it's
essentially a chemical process chemical
and and mechanical process but you get
less out than you put in make sure that
this language doesn't enshrine in
statute something that's not technically
correct uh Mr chairman I I would
definitely uh underscore the fact that a
battery is not an energy generator
because the only time I would believe
that as a physicist is if you can get
more energy out of it then you put in
that's right and it's generating if you
get less energy than you put in or the
same it's just an energy storage device
not a
generator but you're right about the
chemic reaction part of it yeah you're
converting energy into chemical energy
and then you're getting energy back out
of it but it never brings you more
energy than you put
CL I'll try to get to the right distance
so people actually understand me uh um
every generator on the face of the Earth
has more energy going in that comes out
so so what your your point to me is not
on point but I thought that when I heard
the language about for load red purposes
solves the problem that chairman Vose is
trying to fix that it's it's being it's
not treated as a generator because it's
being used as a load reducer so if you
put Lo for load reducing purposes it
might fix your concern Mr
chairman
yeah okay thanks does anybody uh else
have any other issues with the language
please
if not let's could you give us 30
seconds
you we test we test Mak that St a
separate class we pass
that making that a separate class
that
storage I was confused where it going
here I thought we did okay 30 seconds is
oops I set the timer in case you didn't
seconds
now now I can't turn it
off okay so I guess we're all done with
uh section one of Senate Bill 92 now
let's move on to part two section two
relative to hydroelectric generators
that share equipment for purposes of
interconnection to the electric
grid I don't have any issues with this
else
repres representative Samson you have
your hand raised do you have a issue
here
or no I don't Mr chairman I forgot to
lower my hand okay thank
you representative o i I have a question
go ahead thank you very much are is it
possible for us to have another work
session next week where we could have
um I'm not
sure I'll have to check with the house
clerk to
see
uh when we can schedule another section
that's proper another session that's
properly
noticed and it it might be in next
Wednesday or Thursday before we could
get a get a session scheduled and then
I'll have to check with um the
schedulers to see if there's any rooms
ailable so I can check into that um
thank you very much I'll let you
know okay and I guess there's nothing on
section two or part two part three Mr
chairman uh representative just a
question on on part two my notes say
that there this essentially applies to
only three independent Hydra facilities
is that true or do I have that wrong
correct part three of the bill is about
low moderate income Community solar
projects it fixes a mistake that was
introduced into
legislation um
previously and um I don't have any
issues with this one there's anybody
else part
three part
three
okay so now we can move on and get to
the meet of this work
session which is to discuss part four
and just a quick reminder to everybody
we are going to be deleting the part
five from Senate Bill
91 so earlier today I sent out a
um proposed change
to part four of Senate Bill
91 and this
proposal came from a meeting of a group
of two meetings actually of a group of
uh stakeholders were concerned about
this
issue uh the issue of limited electrical
energy
producers
and I worked with uh The Honorable
Clifton Belo to come up with language he
came up with most of it I'll confess
because he's an excellent drafter of
legislation and
um this proposed legislation addresses
three
issues one issue is what is the dividing
line between
the transmission
system and the distribution
system why is that important because the
transmission system is governed by FK
and ISO New England and the distribution
system is governed by the state and the
Commission therefore comingling the two
runs into
jurisdictional questions
and this legislation attempts to address
degree the second issue it tries to deal
with is the issue of avoided
transmission
costs and whether or not they could be
shifted to
non-limited
electricity energy
producing producers or
customers and the solution that this
legislation comes up with and we'll talk
about the specific language in a minute
is to restrict the transaction path of
any of these
sales
to distribu distribution grid only on
the same distribution
grid there the transmission system is
of of jural questions never uh arises
because there is no uh conflict between
the
two and then the third issue that the
legislation addresses or the the
proposed legislation addresses is the
issue of
making sure that customers are protected
all around and U the legislation
addresses that by requiring that the
Public Utilities Commission initiate rul
making to uh establish the producers the
the rules rather for um eliminate
enabling limited producers to sell
electricity at wholesale within
interstate
commerce and uh so those are the
three big questions that this bill tries
to
uh what I would like to do
next
is is ask the honorable Clifton Belo to
walk us
through uh the portions of the
legislation the proposed legislation
that he worked on and explained to us
just exactly how it accomplishes its
goals so Mr B Belo if you could take
over and talk about this bill I'd
gratefully appreciate it sure happy to
do that uh thank you chairman Vose
um um we you know we um I we pulled
together um the stakeholders that we
could identify which included inviting
all the utility clean energy New
Hampshire Grand State Hydro uh and both
represent V and mcke because mcke
represent mcke had sponsored a similar
Bill uh as well as all the Senators who
were sponsors of the legislation and and
that was the group that discussed this
and and and eversource does have some of
the jurisdictional concerns and we've
we've tried to address those to the you
know and and kind of air on the side of
um this language being um conservative
taking a smaller step not uh pushing the
bounds of that jurisdictional question
uh too much so um just to walk through
it I think you have the PDF I'll refer
to those um page and line numbers the
first page this in effect this is
obviously not a legislative Services
Amendment but it it shows really the
entire text to part four um as it might
possibly be amended here in this
proposal uh so the so the first section
line 7 through 15 is you know the
definition section of the whole chapter
it is um it it is making trying to make
clear that this um legislation or this
uh opportunity as it exists in current
law this is a sort of a repeal and
replace of the current law um does allow
limited producers um which more clearly
in this definition are such a size uh
that they don't have to register to par
participate in the iso New England
regulated um uh wholesale electricity
Market um and this only adds that
clarification that they do not actually
participate in either net metering which
which is sort of a different way of
getting compensated or and are not um
registered as a generator or asset or
network resource within ISO New England
and doesn't participate in F
jurisdictional wholesale electricity
markets with one exception and that
that's one uh that's spelled on on like
12 that's new compared to the bill as
introduced although I addressed it in my
my testimony in the original here on the
bill and that says except as an
alternative technology regulation
resource uh which is actually the term
used by ISO New England uh also
abbreviation atrr to the extent atrrs
are deemed by ISO New England to
function as retailer Network load
reducers for all other ISO New England
purposes so so what that says is ISO New
England um has determined that
atrrs can be a regulation resource this
is primarily battery storage um but not
otherwise participating their markets
and they're still treated as a load
reducer relative to the calculation of
cost of of transmission cost allocation
and that that was in a slide from an ISO
New England presentation that was
recently made that makes that
distinction and it's in their
regulations as well so so it would allow
battery uh that only functions as an
atrr uh to still function as load
reducer to the extent that how ISO New
England treats them as well so that
that's a minor point but I just wanted
to F
that if I guess I Mr chairman I I will
sort of pause at each section I'm
addressing and see if there's questions
does that sound good yes that sounds
excellent any questions for um it looks
like representative oxenham has a
question about that first
section thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you Mr Belo uh could you just walk
through that definition again I'm this
atrr um yes well it's it's defined in a
document called op14 operational
procedure 14 in which they elaborate all
the different ways that any kind of
resource might participate in the
electricity uh generation ancillary
market and capacity markets um so
there's a definition for generator uh
there's a definition for atrr which
which is which as near as I can tell is
pretty much just batteries although it
could be smart inverters um things that
can provide um a regulation resource
like doing power factor
correction or voltage support or
frequency regulation uh those are um the
type of Regulation resources that are
typically delivered by the bulk grid uh
but all the market participants have
determined that sort of smaller scale
storage devices or smart inverters uh
could provide some of these resources at
the call of iso New England so they've
created a special program where these
things that aren't really like
traditional generators um they're not
participating in the generation markets
but they can provide some regulation
resource where they can call upon them
and compensate them and but still allow
them to just operate like if they're
part of net metering just allow them to
operate in the distribution grade
because they're small enough scale that
they don't otherwise have to participate
in those markets and they they could
just be selling locally which is what
this bill is trying to enable thank
[Music]
you okay I'll move
on I've got another question there oh
sure uh yes Mr Belo um I I've I've heard
it referenced before in this context
that some of these services are referred
to as ancillary Services is is that the
equivalent of what the alternative
technology regulation resources because
an Services could be um services that
provide some type of synchronization or
stabilization of the grid right um I I
can't answer that definitively because
I'm not quite as familiar perhaps as I I
would like to be about this atrr program
but but but it it's a does get called
upon to provide some regulation service
and that synchronization is part of what
what goes on in regulation service and
that there are actually markets for that
they're really tiny tiny part of the
electricity rates but that they're part
of the electricity Supply rate and part
of that is a voltage support power
factor correction frequency regulation
um sometimes it's just like very quick
response so like if a big generation
unit suddenly went offline to keep the
grid from destabilizing you want to call
upon a bunch of really quick response
resources to correct you know to support
um how power is being regulated and uh
so that that's where they carved out an
exception for sort of um otherwise State
regulated storage devices and said well
if we can just call upon them to help in
sort of these emergency situations we'd
like to be able to do that but you can
still have sort of a regulatory
Authority at the State uh level
otherwise for these for this particular
purpose because because it's valuable
okay thank you very
much okay Mr bow continue okay at the
bottom of page one line 33 um some of
that language is was already there in
the bill but um I think the chairman um
correctly said let's make it clear that
the commission does rulle making to set
up the parameters for how this works and
to be honest I expect that rule making
to take quite a while uh because you
know could easily take a year more it is
part of you know what the commission
wanted to address as part of grid
modernization so so in that sense you
know there are issues to be thought
through
um working with the utilities and the
commission and and how this relates um
sort of iso to ISO New England as well
so this just makes clear the commission
initiates rulemaking uh uh to to set the
procedures for this uh further establish
requirements and conditions concerning
it um that they deem necessary to avoid
substantial risk or uncompensated cost
to the electric utility uh in the
franchise area where the sales takes
place so that that's all in the current
bill uh new language here um is to say
expressly uh that the commission shall
have the authority by rule or by order
following notice in hearing this is the
top of page two um to determine if there
is any unjust or unreasonable cost
shifting in transmission rates arising
from any credits for avoided
transmission charges pursuant to
paragraph five that's the next section
of of the law and upon find such finding
to remediate such cost shifting which
may include on a perspective basis
reasonably reducing the credit for
actual avoided transmission charges so
that that's a mouthful but it makes very
clear the commission can and and um uh
take action uh this this could be on
their own initiative or request of
utility or the request of any citizen
can can initiate um the commission um
taking a look at this question of if
there's any U cost shifting and and
unjust or unreasonable is the term of
art just and reasonable are the terms of
art that are really well established in
case law uh around how the Pu regulates
utilities and and the relationship with
customers and and generators so um uh
that that gives them the authority to do
it and and it goes on and makes clear
that on a perspective B basis they could
reduce the credit uh to make sure that
there isn't cost shifting um so right
now the way the Bill's written it sort
of posi posits there it's the equivalent
of a 95% credit to you know 100% of the
avoided costs but if the commission said
well actually some of those costs come
back you know we could reduce that to
say 90% but it gives the commission to
to adjust that to avoid any uh unjust or
unreasonable cost
shifting so that is is that's long
sentence is at line seven and I'll pause
there for a moment if there's any
questions on that yes I have a quick
question yes on line four
where the language
says shifting in transmission rates
arising arising from any credits for
avoided transmission
charges yes is transmission rates the
proper place to look for cost
shifting um I can't see where it would
occur otherwise unless you wanted to
start counting the additional benefits
which sort of has shift in the the other
direction um but but they they wouldn't
just as an example such um distributed
generation that's not participating in
the iso New England Market at the same
um hour that it might reduce uh
transmission charges from what they'd
otherwise be it would also produce lower
capacity charges to the distribution
utility as a whole
um and uh
arguably there might be some credit for
that but I I don't think that should
occur within the parameters of this
statute um because that just kind of
complicates thing it's sort of a
different
Market um or or different potential
avoided cost um you could for
arising I mean you could say for avoided
trans arising from any credits I'm not
sure where they what they'd arise from
otherwise but you could say arising from
any credits for void voided transmission
charges or or
um other cost um or you know for avoided
transmission charges pursuant to
paragraph five or from any other source
or from from any other cost you could
say something like that I I just can't
think of
any and then upon such finding to
remediate such cost shifting
um there is
reason I
ra to clarify the reason I raised
question is because farther down in line
20 we're talking about um these
sales happening exclusively on the same
distribution
grid yes to avoid involving the
transmission grid as much as possible so
that's why I'm wondering yes how
transmission rates factor into
the into the question of avoiding trans
you know of avoided
transmission charges being shifted
[Music]
somewhere um we can talk about this
offline why don't you go ahey well it
does go to a point I'm gonna get to in a
second um so I'll come back to it in a
way but let's go and look at what lines
7 through 14 say and this sort of pulls
in some language back from the current
statute um that the chair thought is
important and uh to protect um rate pays
retail rate paays in particular uh so I
think you know that that it's a
reasonable idea um so what it says is
the commission shall review all
contracts concerning retail sale of
electricity pursuant to this section and
I think those words are actually this is
actually pretty much current law um just
going to glance at it
yeah yeah this is pretty much you know
pulled right out of the current law um
which in its judgment fails to protect
both parties against excessive liability
or undo risk or B entails substantial
cost or risk to the electric utility in
whose franchise area their sale takes
place or C is inconsistent with the
public good and again the public good is
one of those words that's used a lot in
in the Pu statutes and is um concept
that's well established in case law um
and then it goes on this is new compared
to current statute such review shall not
require a contested case meaning you
don't have to have an adjudicated
proceeding that can take a year more um
and failure to disapprove such contract
within 60 days of filing with the
commission shall constitute approval
thereof so so you you know when you can
go ahead and execute the contract if
they haven't disapproved it the the
current statute is written as a negative
they may disapprove it it doesn't say
they have to approve it so you know 60
days and that's what the commission
asked for in reviewing um uh electric
power aggregation um plans electric
aggregation
plans repes PL has a question if you
pause thank you m thank you Mr chair um
it's back on page one lines 33 to 35 I
wasn't part of your working group I have
brought this up but that that language
makes no sense to me perhaps you can
walk me through it the commission shall
initiate rulemaking to establish
procedures to enable limited producers
electricity at wholesale with inter
interestate Commerce and at retail
either directly or indirectly through
electricity suppliers yes I don't
understand that wholesale or retail and
what's how how do you do it directly
through an electricity supplier um well
um I think a a
direct sell to sell electricity at
wholesale within intra within State
Commerce that can be done directly uh to
or with an electricity supplier that
that's even current law um this this is
only um those generators that are not uh
participating in the F jurisdictional
market and and and hence are not f
jurisdictional um and
so what it's saying is that there's two
ways this could occur um this limited
producer it's a limited within State
market and they could sell at wholesale
uh to A supplier which is a defined term
elsewhere in the statute it's
essentially a load serving entity or
they could sell at retail direct from
producer to Consumer but you would have
to go through an electricity supplier um
so let me just give you an example um
the city of Lebanon is working to
develop a one megawatt Landfield Gas
Energy project um we
could because it would be exactly one
megawatt um we could do it with group
navig metering um would be one way to do
it an alternative way under this statute
would be to do that in which case
there'd be two possibilities if if say
if we had Lebanon Community power up and
running and we have a bunch of
residential and Commercial customers we
could say because this acts like a
certain amount of Base load we know our
loads always greater than what this
producers we we could we could just buy
that buy Lebanon Community power to
supply customers right here in the city
of Lebanon um like we would with group
net metering or um there are some we
might say well we don't want to take
that credit risk for Lebanon Community
power because you know we're not sure
that that rate's a good one for the long
term but we've got some businesses we've
got hyperm we got Nova Doris we got
Dartmouth College we have the school
district we have the city itself um we
all be interested in taking strips of
that power so we will contract for PPA
for strips of that power that we expect
is always going to be uh less than than
our load and and so 11 can be Power by
the balance because you have to be a
full service you know full load
following service we would buy the
balance of that power uh say from the
iso New England wholesale Market um but
it would be Lebon conven power if it was
a load serving entity or competitive
electricity supplier who would have to
account for all of this who has to um
well there's some words elsewhere in in
the statute um
but uh the electricity supplier it would
have to go through them either um
directly or indirectly um I I think the
indirectly would be if it they're just
facilitating a PPA with an individual
customer uh and there aren't actually
sort of taking title to the power
because the customer is taking title to
it in real time then that would be
indirectly through the electricity
supplier or directly would be okay we
buy it and we turn around and sell it uh
use it as part of our supply obligation
for our customer mix right here in
Lebanon does that explain
it your defining supplier in this case
is Lebanon uh entity this Lebanon entity
well the in the example I'm giving um
but supplier um is defined elsewhere in
statute such that what it is in effect
it's an entity that has to be registered
with the PC um and it is has to be
essentially a load serving entity
registered with ISO New England as well
because you can't provide full load
following service unless you're a
wholesale Market participant as a load
serving entity with ISO New England so
that that's a you know the electricity
supplier is that kind you know
it it's an entity that is a load serving
entity both as understood at the state
level okay thank you uh continue on
please
okay um so continuing on um we're on
page two at line 15 and there there's
actually a deletion here that I'll just
call your attention to um because
because it's sort of relevant to the
last couple of points um says The
Limited
producer uh shall receive credit for
actual avoided transmission charges and
that says only to the extent the current
bill okay
okay um right I was I think somebody s
muted maybe Jackie um just a moment um
took care of it okay uh I'm just trying
to put my fingers on the Bell as it came
to you um so I can make the correct
comparison here we
go the bill as it came to you said The
Limited producer or the purchasers of
their output as determined by the
commission shall re receive credit for
actual voided transmission
charges well that's because that's sort
of in current law right now it allows
the possibility the purchasers could get
credit for avoided transmission
charges whether there's well actually
for for transmission charges whether
they're actually avoided or not which is
one of the problems with the current law
it basically says you could just cancel
out your 2.22 cents or 2.5 cents per
kilowatt hour for
transmission um if you're getting that
generation from a limited producer and
um as a practical matter that would be
very hard for the utilities to
administer um and it also really
confuses how this credit is working so I
I suggested to this stakeholder group
that maybe it would be better just to
take that out of there and and nobody
really objected and at least one utility
thought that was a good idea on my own I
think because they didn't um you know
don't want to have to do that kind of
calculation uh and it also would
implicate the distribution utility and
doing more accounting for it than than
the supplier um so to make a long story
short what what this means is that all
customers that receive energy all
customers that receive energy would
continue to pay the transmission rate
whether they their
supplier uh is a limited producer um
that doesn't actually cause transmission
costs or not and to the extent so in in
essence what those customers say say
let's just say hypothetically we sold
all of our output from
um our one megawatt landfill gas to
project energy to project to one entity
um and actually the only entity that I
know that's big enough to take that
entire load uh that and it be less than
their total load would be either say
dhmc the hospital or or Dartmouth
College say
um um but T take dhmc because it's
actually in Lebanon they they always
have a megawatt more than a megawatt of
load so if we were selling them the
entire Mega
they would continue to pay their
transmission charge but it would
essentially most of their what they're
paying for transmission would would end
up uh going to the gas project which in
turn could negotiate a rate that takes
that into account and might make it
economically feasible compared to say
group net metering
um so the point is to was to just in and
take um credits to the purchaser out of
the picture
and um so we're always collecting the
same amount for transmission charges the
question is does that all go to pay
actual transmission or does some of it
go to compensate avoided transmission at
less than the full uh rate if you will
um so um just going on from there
because this is another long sentence to
get an idea important idea cross uh so
they would only get credit for actual
avoided transmission charges to the
extent that transmission charges
allocated to the distribution utility
are reduced from what they would
otherwise be absent the electricity
exported to the distribution grid by the
Limited producer during hours of
coincident Peak on which transmission
costs are allocated that that's all um
you know just a description of how how
actual avoided transmission costs can
occur and and here's the new language
compared to the bill as you got it from
the
Senate and only if the contract or
physical path for the electrical energy
between limited producer and
consumer that is uh the seller to the
buyer generator to Consumer seller to
buyer can occur exclusively on the same
distribution grid such that FK
jurisdictional transmission is not
required as part of such transaction
path um so just I'll just pause right
there until I read the uness part um so
what that's saying
is you know if the producer and the
consumer um are actually in the same
behind the same interface between the
transmission and the distribution grid
so that the entire transaction is
occurring exclusively within State
jurisdictional distribution grid and
with a in the state's authority to
regulate inra within State wholesale
Commerce but only for generators that
aren't participating that in the FK uh
jurisdictional Market um then um uh that
that that's a new limitation that wasn't
in the bill as it came from the Senate
um because they only had to be in the
same uh franchise area not necessarily
in the same part of the distribution
grid this came up because the way ever
sources uh transmission and distrib
assets are arranged in New Hampshire um
it's not like they have one big
distribution grid what they have is a
bunch of FK jurisdictional uh trans
transmission that is part of what's
called their local network service
meaning it primarily serves eversource
not other customers u in interstate
commerce so a lot of their 115 KV or all
their 115 KV and a chunk of their 69 KV
uh transmission lines are for
jurisdictional and they have somewhere
on the order of two or three dozen or
more uh different points in which the
distribution grid across New Hampshire
is interconnected but really only
through or primarily through these
transmission assets so this is saying
that the transactions that get um
avoided transmission credit only occurs
if they're really in the same part of
the grid um you know I wasn't fully
aware that they have so many take points
um from the transmission into
distribution so in a sense they're
operating you know several dozen small
distribution grids because I'm sort of
used to the Liberty Utilities model
where the whole um their whole franchise
territory here in the Upper Valley um is
all behind just um a couple of uh
transmission points and and and we're
all interconnected as as one
distribution grid so our thought was you
know um if you if we had a Regional
Community power aggregation or a
supplier serving the region uh
competitive supplier then they could
conduct the transition transactions
within this part of the territory and
the actual physical effect would be to
reduce the load on the transmission grid
that would also be the contract path is
just on the distribution grid and under
current um tariffs that are being
clarified right now at ISO New England
uh that would be would actually function
as a load reducer just like Energy
Efficiency or demand response um and
function to reduce um the network load
on which transmission costs are
calculated so that's that mouthful and
then the unless to finish the sentence
is that um unless the commission finds
after notice and hearing meaning an
adjudicated proceeding where people can
present evidence and legal argument uh
that such an state within state sales of
electricity are within the jurisdiction
of the state and commission to regulate
and are consistent with RSA 374f colon 3
Roman 4 providing for non-discriminatory
open access to dist transmission and
distribution facilities um so that
that's that's a mouthful that particular
statute is referenced at the end of the
bill on page three uh there's a section
six to the bill uh which actually has
the it it it says it's repealed and
reenacted but but I'm not sure that's
necessary because I think this is the
entire U language of the current statute
as cited um and that was a basic concept
that the start of restructuring was that
all generators um all uh uh consumers
potentially where appropriate wholesale
or retail uh should um have
non-discriminatory open access to the
system u meaning you know people like
situated are treated in the same way um
and uh you know at that time we were
saying companies providing transmission
should file at firk or or with the state
Commission as appropriate comparable
service tariffs that provide open access
for all competitors and that the
commission should monitor those
companies providing T andd and take
measures to ensure no supplier has an
unfair advantage in offering or pricing
such services that was you know way back
in
1996 and that was right around the same
time FK was operating developing a
similar policy under F order 888 uh for
open access to transmission um and
that's the kind of tarff New England
develop uh so the long short of that is
is simply to say okay you can't you
don't get credit for these kinds of
transactions u u unless there's a
subsequent determination that that's
really within the state's regulatory
Authority and it's consistent with our
restructuring principles on this matter
um and there's so little I'm just going
to sort of finish up then then go back
to questions if I may um the
um there were some a few words deleted
here because it used to assume that
there was always a meter point between
um transmission and distribution that's
probably true for Liberty Unitil and the
co-op but but it turns out eversource
doesn't actually have meter points
meters between their tnd interface at
least some if not many of their um uh
tnd grid uh so you can't actually
measure the flow at those locations um
uh so it this just just changed to say
The Credits based on measurement of
exports to the distribution Grid at the
retail meter Point without additional CR
credit for avoided line and
transformation losses between the retail
point and the transmission grid and
that's to make sure there's some benefit
for for other customers and I've kind of
explained this before but in general uh
there's an estimate there's about
roughly a 7% transformation and line
loss between where power comes over the
transmission grid and where it actually
gets consumed B retail meters uh so if
you if you supply one megawatt at retail
you probably have to buy 1.07 megawatts
at wholesale um if if you only
compensate avoided transmission cost on
the one then there's a Delta between
that that 100% And 107% if you will um
there's still going to be some fraction
of a scent or so of of line loss even
between the limited producer and the
next door neighbor that that will all
set load very near buy so there's
minimal line losses but still some so
I'm assuming there's maybe on the order
of five or 6% um savings uh because
you're not having to gross up so there's
actually sort of um a bit of a financial
benefit at at this stage for for
non-participants if you will um so
that's that's the bulk of the bill the
section five of the bill on page three
I'll just touch on that briefly uh this
is something um that's just there to
ensure comparable treatment between
generation and storage that participates
in that metering and those that might
participate as a limited producer uh
because right now if you're up to one
megawatt and you participate in net
metering and group net metering uh you
would be exempt from the Statewide
utility property tax um and and so line
67 89 just clarify that if you're also
if you're up to an including one
megawatt limited producer you would
likewise be exemp but if you're in the
one to five megawatt range you would not
be exempt and that's sort of an
important concept because it was thought
that that you know this was sort of a
thing that was to not lose revenue for
the one to five gener megawatt
generators that um even you know even if
net maning was expanded it it would
limit them to one to to this exemption
to one megawatt and under so um if for
instance our Lan fasta energy project if
it were to be privately owned it would
be owned by the city as we're planning
it now but if it was privately owned and
participating group net metering it
would be exemp but if it right now under
current law if they participated instead
in a market-based sale as a limited
producer then they would um uh not be
exempt and that that alone would would
make the limited producer option perhaps
um disadvantageous to the point where
where nobody under one megawatt would do
it so this just tries to ensure
comparable treatment for one megawatt
producers that function as a load
reducer uh you know according to ISO New
England generation tariff transmission
tariff policies um and as I mentioned
section six of the bill that this draft
language is is for reference it's unless
unless represent V is amended the
language it's the same as what's in
current statute so I did not uh amend it
I
misread your email and thought that you
did uh rewrite it I added it to the bill
so if I hear you correctly we don't need
this section no we correct I just put it
I put it in the email to you so you
could see what what the uh proposed
language in the amendment option it uh
references okay got it uh representative
ssuch has a question sure yes uh thank
you Mr chair
actually I've got two questions uh as
usual uh uh Mr Belo is always so
thorough and so detailed that um goes by
pretty quickly so so uh on page two uh
the section with um 15 through guess
24 um you mentioned and I want to
clarify what you meant there is you
mentioned that all customers would be
paying transmission costs yes and then
you threw in a little curveball talking
something about your landfill gas and
that you you could shift shift some of
the the cost from the transmission
charges to your landfill gas and do
something miraculously um can you
explain what you meant there and how how
does the transmission charges affect
everybody and why is that a good
idea sure um right now um we have uh
very little if any development of 1 to 5
megawatt um New Generation new renewable
generation and storage in New Hampshire
it's it's too big to participate in new
net metering and TP and too small uh to
be worth participating in the iso New
England
markets um this is to try to create a
market for those producers
um I fully expect they would get a lot
less compensation than the generation
than the full default service energy
rate that you can get under net
metering um but but they don't but under
net metering if you're more than 100 KW
you don't get any credit for any actual
voided transmission
cost right now all that net meter
generation between 100 KW on one
megawatt functions almost all of it
except except for a few that ever
sources registered to be holesale Market
participants but but all the rest of it
um all of the 100 to one megawatt
generation for instance in net net meter
generation in Liberties territory it all
functions as a load reducer relative to
transmission cost allocation so um just
to take a hypothetical let let's say we
have um 20 megawatts of load in in the
Lebanon New Hampshire and 10 of it is
being provided by default service and 10
of it is being provided uh through
Lebanon Community power and um right now
if all of that was being served from
bulk generators that were buying from
ISO New England markets both for default
and Lebanon Community power we would pay
for 20
megawatts um of of at at the
transmission rate which is roughly
$130 per KW per month or per year um uh
so so we'd be paying for transmission
costs based on 20
megawatts and you might say well that
should be megawatt hours but it's
actually 100 or 20 megawatts at the
single hour of monthly coincident Peak
so it's the same as 20 megawatt hours
it's it's sort of 20 megawatts of
average demand over the peak hour um we
would pay that um you know spread out
over the course of the Year based on
each monthly coincident Peak so that's
around 10 11 bucks per kilowatt month um
you would pay that to ISO New England
for transmission if you reduce that 20
megaw to say 19 through Energy
Efficiency in the Energy Efficiency
programs we would say we can justify the
utility investing in Energy Efficiency
because they avoid one megawatt of
transmission charges and that actually
goes into the mathematical calculation
for where utility investment Energy
Efficiency is is economically justifi if
we do the same thing with um uh uh
locally based demand response I demand
response that's not participating in ISO
New England uh markets if we curtail
load by one megawatt we also reduce our
charges by one
megawatt and
um if but but that case you know the C
the customer well and so in the third
instance example if we put on one
megawatt of local generation that
produces one megawatt at at the system
peak hour each month or every month uh
it doesn't have to do it every month but
each month they get a partial credit A
month's worth of credit uh if we put on
one megawatt of of local uh distributed
generation under five megawatts then um
what we see for what's called Network
load drops from 20 to 19 megawatts for
for transmission cost
allocation but we're still collecting
the same amount from all the consumers
because what happens at the Pu is we the
pu's obligation the puc controls the
rates that retail customers pay
including what how generators who are
net metered are compensated so the Pu
takes what is sort of a demand charge
and turns it into a flat rate per
kilowatt hour so everybody customers
don't pay based on their share of the
coincident Peak they pay just per
kilowatt hour so all the customers
continue to pay at the same per kilowatt
hour rate but instead of buying 20
megawatt hours with what they're paying
we're buying 19 from the wholesale
market and and we're buying essentially
one from from The Limited producer but
we're only giving them credit for 95% of
what they produce and the Pu could
reduce that further if they need to
avoid cost shifting um so that's how
they avoided cost is sort of being
redirected to the generator but for or
the storage device but for which we
would have had to pay the transmission
system does that make sense I I kind of
wanted to diagram this out visually but
but
um that's it basically okay thank you so
I have a second question um and that is
um as you described the eversource
transmission and distribution system I
think you mentioned that um there is not
a meter at the intersection of each
transmission line to each distribution
line correct does that mean that
eversource pretty much uses the
transmission lines to distribute its
energy to the various distribution uh
branches uh so that that is they're
using parts of the transmission as a
distribution Network as well and um if
it's not being
metered um how how do they uh assess the
transmission cost that way um I think
you'd have to ask them that question um
what what what I
know is BEC let me compare it with
Liberty where they do have a meter
point
Liberty still has to estimate what all
the retail load is because they don't
they like eversource do not have
interval meters so they actually don't
know who's consuming how much at that
hour coincident Peak so they have very
complex algorithms mathematical models
to take their wholesale meter reading
point and guesstimate what the retail
meter readings are and and and to figure
out what the loss is in between and to
um uh to figure their Network load
actually the network load is easy to
figure because it's all metered it's
that wholesale retail I mean distri
transmission distribution interface um
so they then just have to allocate that
out um well I'm kind of jumping between
transmission and and uh annual capacity
costs let me slow down here um let me
see
um yes so whatever
Source I I think there are need meters I
suspect there are meters between the
regional transmission system which is
called the pooled transmission
facilities because it's part of What's
called the regional network service
which is the really true high voltage um
Interstate Regional transmission that
all load in New Hampshire pay for
proportionate to their share of
coincident
peak in addition to that we have a bunch
of non-pooled transmission facilities
which are what's called local network
service and it primarily serves
customers of one um distrib one parent
company I should say so eversource owns
transmission primarily in Connecticut
Massachusetts and New Hampshire a little
bit goes into Maine and stuff like that
but um that their portion of their
transmission that it's not part of the
pooled trans transmission facilities is
and really operated by ISO New England
that portion which is part of their
local network it's still an interstate
Network though be because it is um well
because it's been classified that way
primarily but but it also may involve
some transmission of of Interstate
transmission of electricity um uh so but
but it's all sort of pulled together in
one rate they they get to charge their
local network costs to all of the uh
retail uh load that gets power over that
so by and large the distribution system
don't really interconnect directly with
the uh pooled transmission facilities
they more typically connect with the
regional networks um so like uh Liberty
connects to National Grids uh Network
you know because they used to own the
Distribution Company and and National
Grid also serves in you know Rhode
Island and Massachusetts as well um I
mean it's sort of a leftover artifact
from when these were vertically
integrated so I believe that there are
meter points between the regional
Network and the local networks and
because they have to be able to
calculate the line losses on each
Network separately um and so eversource
must know what they're paying for from
the regional Network and then they have
fancy mathematical models that
extrapolate from where they do have
meters at this interface to where they
don't and then does a true up months
later once they actually read the
monthly bills and they scale it all
accordingly and they they have a a way
of estimating how much they're actually
getting off of their Regional Network um
so it's an estimation process that
that's all I know for
sure thank you thank you Mr Belo I think
that's enough okay thanks Cliff can't
give you a headache KY bits has a
question yes I do
um I hesitate cliff you know I bring
everything down to the re's
digest one of the things we heard
about renewable energy in general was
the uh effect on the grid because of the
intermittent energy so if this thing
takes
off are there going to
be winners and losers and and and I say
this very simplistically in other words
I put a system in my house or on my
backyard or wherever that can
store X number of energy now there we're
in Peak or and we need the
energy am I going to be able
to give that back at will or is the
company going to have to ask me for that
and is and again are they going to be
winners and losers and is they going to
be some control over what's going back
onto the
grid um and the other the other thing
again the read is digest are there going
to be contracts for this so if I have
the
system and it's never
used or they don't need it or they have
too much if this thing really takes
off is there going to be a contract with
me that well whether we whe whether
somehow you put it back or not or
whatever we're gonna pay you for it
those are two things and you don't maybe
have to answer them but they thoughts
and there things that I would like
clarified in my sure um well first of
all you get no credit unless you can
actually prove it and that's we're
having a revenue grade interval meter
comes into place because at the end of
the month or some weeks after the end of
the month the
utilities know in ISO new Eng
knows exactly which
hour um like right right now we're well
we're only 3 days into May sometime
later in May they'll have done all their
um checks on all the numbers and they'll
say with some confidence that back on
April you know 17th at hour ending 500m
that was the system Peak for April and
you only get credit if you actually
reduce transmission costes from what
they would
otherwise be right at that hour so the
the winner if you will is the type of
resource that can actually be
dispatched either by potentially the
utility um because they do you know
that's what Liberty doing with their
battery pilot or by a price signal um or
like a a demand response provider that
or you're through your supplier I mean
that's typically where it happens our
supplier our competitive electric
supplier for the city of Lebanon does
this now for the annual system Peak
which is also that month's transmission
Peak and they say look we think there's
a peak coming you want to curil your
load for these three or four hours um if
you have battery storage dispatch it to
try to meet this peak um and and if you
and if you hit that if you actually hit
that Peak then you get credit for it if
you miss the peak you don't get credit
so if if in a sense compared to net
metering the loser might be do F south
facing solar which
optimizes you know produces the most
kilowatt
hours per dollar of investment but it
may not do that much to help shave the
system Peak because only half of the
year is the system Peak even during
daylight hours and even in the months
where it's daylight hours it's tends to
be in the mid to late afternoon um so
they may or may not be producing and and
if the system Peak moves later and later
in the in the day then they there may be
less and less credit for a system that
can't uh produce if you will you know
like where's the beef if you can't
produce during the hour of system Peak
there is no credit under this and and
you're it's just a energy market-based
energy transaction between you and
another consumer or or supplier on your
local part of the distribution grid just
like net metering is in many respects
except
um we're keeping default service and the
the distribution utility out of the
energy transaction part of this so
that's all market-based
um that might partially answer your
control I swear there would have to be a
contract between any retail consumer um
I would suspect that those would only be
large scale at least initially although
there might be some community solar
programs where people want to um enter
into a long-term PPA just like they do
for behind the meter those would be
reviewed by the P pu if they're going to
create problems they could um uh
disapprove those contracts
um okay I just and the other concern I
have is
that trying to keep up with all this is
is crazy my brain doesn't function that
well but how we are
intermingling or intermixing our own
regulations with what may be coming down
from the federal government and what we
have done in weeks past so I I think we
need to look at that and I I did I did
send a send out an email um but only in
the hour only during the lunch hour uh
that
includes yeah that includes an image
from um an ISO New England presentation
from last summer that shows this idea of
developing these local markets for
distributed energy resources because
quite honestly they're like too much for
for ISO New England to to want to be
concerned about or to have their kind of
metering requirements for there are tens
and tens of thousands of
disted uh generation uh generators now
operating under net metering in New
England that and this is where ISO New
England has sort of complain we don't
have visibility into those but if we had
this kind of local market particularly
for the 1 to 5 megawatt
there would be visibility because they
would have to have interval metering and
you'd see what they're doing when and if
they're selling through a producer to a
retail customer they're going to want to
align their production with the
consumption of those customers um so so
um I think the only point is yeah this
is Tech Technical and complicated but
but this is something that a lot of the
sort of thought leaders in this field
are saying this is something we need to
better integrate these intermittent
sources where you give the appropriate
price signals that that you might want
to couple them with storage because
there's more value if you can dispatch
that uh stored energy even if it's only
one or two megawatts at at system peak
times and inevitably to hit the single
hour you're going to have to hit a bunch
of hours and ultimately this becomes
win-win-win because you're encouraging
both local production local demand
response local storage to help shave our
Peaks which typically means we're going
to fill the
which means we're spreading all the
costs for Peak capacity over more
kilowatt hours rather than fewer
kilowatt
hours that's the
idea you all I gotta say uh Cliff is
that if all this information exhausts
you the way it does the rest of us must
be tired all the
time here's representative pet he has a
question yes with these Limited Energy
electric producer contracts who who
provides the
reserves when the generator can't
function are you relying on the system
and therefore the transmission well this
is called pay pay for performance if you
will if if if they don't perform I mean
that's the nature of intermittent as
well as small scale demand response
um um you know the point is if we can
systematically and and the fact is the
matter is it's partialed out over every
month of the year um so you've kind of
got to keep
performing month in month out as a peak
shaver if you don't show up uh just like
um if if unexpected load does show up
you the overall system needs the
reserves for that and so there's still a
capacity Market to to make sure we have
those reserves what it's sort of a
stochastic issue when ISO New England
forecasts if they see
consistently that Peak demand is not
growing as fast or is actually shrinking
compared to what they you know had
projected a year ago if they see that
these distributive resources on
average have a certain performance rate
that you can count on then they can
build that into their forecast for more
transmission and generation capacity and
that will feed into what they're trying
to procure in the forward capacity
market so we will continue to procure
reserves will just take into account
what these resources can actually do on
a performance-based
metric rather than the problem with net
metering to my mind is we have no we
have very limited performance-based
metrics we're saying all hours are of
equal value so all kilowatt hours are of
equal value this is a big step towards
saying we need to connect what we
compensate these resources for to when
they actually produce and let value they
actually contribute on
average okay Mr chairman did that answer
your question I'm not sure qu frankly
okay well he gave it a good good sure we
need to wrap this up Mr chairman I have
one more question I promis the committee
would be done around three o'clock so I
notice representative samic has one more
question thank you um well it's just
kind of following on what you just said
Mr Belo I want to remind people how
things have changed what it used to be
to have an old electric bill where you
could get that every month and it told
you exactly how much energy you used and
what what the price was that you paid
for right now I I have to have my own
spreadsheet to make those
determinations and the reason for that
is a couple first of all the Pu has now
allowed you to choose your own energy
supplier so the my bill every month
contains the bill for the energy
supplier then I have solar collectors on
my roof which when I'm not using it I
put into the grid and then I also have a
hybrid vehicle which I charge up uh when
the Sun's shining or from the grid and
of course I have my home so my electric
bill when it comes every month shows me
what my Net usage was from my utility
company but that's not really reflective
of how much energy I actually used in
order for me to calculate that I have to
have my own spreadsheet so my question
is this with all these new complexities
and options that people have it seems to
me we're going to have we're going to
need a more a more
comprehensive uh Billing System that
people know what's going on because
keeping track of it is not
easy um that that's a a fair observation
um which is why in part um I I suggested
you know taking the idea of a credit to
the consumer off because that would
complicate things for the consumer um I
think
primarily this is going to be of
interest to large uh consumers
institutions um businesses that want to
make long-term commitments to local
renewable energy
um the you know and it's also designed
to try to put the work not on the
default service
provider such as the case with net
metering um which is which is the
incumbent utility rather puts the burden
to account for this uh really on the
suppliers um and and to handle these
transactions in the first instance
um there will be work for the Pu to to
sort of Flesh this out so that that's
going to take some time uh but but this
is a concept that's been sort of in
increasingly talked about and uh this is
what happens behind the scenes with any
supplier whether it's the company that
wins default service or
suppliers
uh you know for the co-op or um comp
competitive Supply
or Community power aggregations they
they all have to align up resources uh
to meet their load in real time um and a
portion of that a large portion of that
most of it is through the Interstate
Wholesale Market although some of that's
bilateral at that level sometimes it's
at the they Hadad in real time so
there's a lot of stuff going on behind
the scenes and so I think for the retail
consumer nothing has to change um it
might be that Lebanon Community power
once it gets established in a few years
says you know we're we're managing our
supply on a portfolio basis and we are
comfortable uh doing a long-term
contract with this solar plus storage
project it will probably be with storage
because just the solar alone may not
help you know shave the system Peak that
much um uh and that that's that would be
our Peak probably as well so we're
trying to create something that the
supplier the power aggregation through
probably existing vendors uh can support
this um and not make it difficult for
the individual customer except the
customer just might say you know I want
10% of my power froming coming from
local Renewables and and this is a way
to sign up for
that and and I fixed part of my rate for
the next five years or 10 years you know
this would be prly businesses that say
you know I I'm willing to enter into a
10 or 15 year PPA for some of this power
because I know that that portion of my
power will be a stable rate and you know
and if cost goes up I've got a hedge
against that and if cost go down well
you know but at least I knew it was a
good price at the time and you know and
I made that commitment so
um thank you very much Mr be Mr chairman
if I may my you had a question with
regard to part one of the bill and I
could quickly answer that um oh okay um
you were looking at um oops I don't have
the whole Bell here yes I do
um it was the
23 uh Roman numeral 11 po electricity
markets means yes and it currently the
defin definition is just means energy
capacity or ancillary Services Market
that ISO New England operates and my
suggested add to that was or that may
operate pursuant to RSA
362a colon 2A which is what we were just
talking about
um that under current law creates a very
limited within State wholesale Market
Interstate Wholesale Market as well as a
potential retail Market it's never been
used before but it does that this bill
would update that make it perhaps
actually usable the point being the
purpose of that definition is because
later on it asked the commission to look
at how to compensate energy storage
for
um um avoided transmission costs when
they participate in wholesale markets
well the long and short of this is if
you participate in the iso New England
Market there are no avoided transmission
charges because whatever you produce um
gets counted um if it's on the
distribution grid as part of the network
load in other words you can't
participate in the iso New England
market and get credit for avoiding costs
essentially in that market um and the
same thing is actually true on energy
and capacity if you participate in the
iso New England Market there are no
avoided uh uh capacity energy or in
solary service costs those are all get
applied uh because that power is in
effect selling into that wholesale
market so this just recognizes that
under federal law under Supreme Court
repeated precedent the state has
authority over retail sales and within
State wholesale sales we're allowing
very limited within-state wholesale
sales and those ones may actually be
able to avoid those transmission cost
um so it's just broadening the
definition to recognize
that at least legally there can be more
than one wholesale electricity Market
the interstate one there could also be a
within-state wholesale one that's
Limited in nature and that is defined in
RSA 362a colon 2A essentially part four
of this
bill okay thank you Cliff I'm gonna wrap
up this meeting by asking you one final
question to which I would prefer a yes
or no answer but I know that'll be
difficult for
you the question is are you confident
that the language in the that we've been
discussing here for the last I don't
know hour hour
plus will a prevent any cough shifting
of avoided transmission charges and B
protect all the participants in limited
electrical energy uh
production
exchanges
unequivocally yes okay great thank you
and I appreciate that one- word
answer and with that I well thank you
very much for your hard work on this and
for participating here with us this
afternoon does anybody on the committee
have any further uh comments or
questions Representative
ssuch no sorry I have my hand up but I'm
lowering my
hand okay representative
McGee yes thank you Mr chairman my
question is just procedural it's um are
we going to then turn this document into
an amend and are we going to have a
subsequent meeting scheduled I know you
had mentioned to representative oxenham
earlier that you were going to try and
look for scheduled time next
week yes a good question and thank you
for that here's what I propose to do I
will take the discussions that we had
here today on uh part one of the S
sp91 uh and I will draft a document that
contains the proposed language
changes I won't go to
OS the the
um legislative olss I won't go to OS
with them I will just draft them so that
they look like a drafted Bill language
and then I will send it out to the
committee and I will do the same thing
with language for part four um there
were only a couple of minor changes I
think that we want to make to the
language that U that that we've been
discussing for the last hour and a
half for example removing lines 10
through 19 on page three that's not
necessary so we'll pull that out and
I'll get some clarification with Mr Belo
on question I had had about some wording
in line four on page two and then I'll
recirculate uh those two
documents uh to the committee and we can
talk about them via email um to some
degree then I will also
search or try to get house committee
services to search for additional
meeting times that we might be able to
schedule and notice uh and uh obtain
between now and then probably it'll be
see today's May
be I could notice it by May 6 it
probably have to be May 13th or later uh
before we could have another meeting so
I'll see what I can arrange and I'll get
back to you how's that sound sounds good
okay uh representative pel has a
question yes thank you Mr chairman I'm
just hoping that you will also have a
conversation with Senator Waters and
make sure you're both on the same page
on the um on the uh fair value question
on why that we find that in so many
places I know you're you had a problem
with with that language and just make
sure you're both on the same page that's
all yes thank you for that reminder that
was always my intent I would never make
any changes without running them by
Senator Waters first and Senator avard
too as chair of uh the energy Committee
in the
Senate anybody have anything
else if not it's been a pretty
exhausting day so I will thank you all
for being here and uh I'll keep you
posted about when we'll meet again we'll
certainly meet on the 24th and probably
before that I'll let you know when
so so long everybody and thanks for